Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Da bin ich, Leute.
Start.
Mein Nass ist da.
Netzwerkkarte flashen.
Oh ja, das wird was.
Sekunde, ich muss mich mal kurz hier entknoten.
Mein Headset ist ziemlich durcheinander.
Wartet mal, ich muss kurz rausziehen.
So, da bin ich wieder
entknotet.
Ja.
Quatsch, ich muss ja meine Emotes
noch starten.
Was ist das?
Smart App
Control plockt den App,
Willst du mich verarschen, Windows?
Das ist meine Anwendung.
Die habe ich selbst programmiert.
Wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen?
Windows blockt meine eigene Anwendung.
Okay, wie kann man das...
Okay, wie kann man das jetzt...
Ich muss das doch irgendwie ausführen können.
Wie geht denn das?
Smart App Control, okay.
Smart App Control
Exception.
Smart App Control blocks
untrusted or unsigned applications.
To bypass a block you cannot
add exceptions.
Ernsthaft?
Alter!
Wenn das stimmt.
Microsoft.
euer vibe coded bullshit man fuck mich nicht ab alle ihr drecks penner
das ist doch nicht in ihr ernst jetzt oder was
you can soon disable smart app control ja hoffentlich
Moment, was, was, was, was
If smart app control
Is off
It cannot be turned on without
Reinstalling windows
Sag mal, sind
Sind die wirklich von allen guten
Geistern verlassen mittlerweile
Was ist das denn
Das ist nicht mal
Vibe coded
Das ist, das ist
Vibe-Coded auf dem Raspberry Pi Zero
oder was?
Wollen die mich komplett verarschen?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
dass ich meine eigene Anwendung
wieder ausführen kann.
Außer dieses ganze Zeug ausschalten.
Fickt euch, Microsoft,
Alter. Jetzt würde ich gern hier
den, so wie Linus da,
mit seinem Fuck you in Video,
mit Fuck you Microsoft, Mann.
Alter, wollen die mich komplett verarschen?
Send Feedback, ihr könnt mich mal,
ihr Wichser.
Alter regen die mich auf also sowas kann ich ja überhaupt nicht
Ist mein computer ich will auf meinem computer ausführen können was ich will und wenn ich sage das ist meine app die will ich black
Die will ich weitlisten dann mache ich das
Get apps from the app store ja garantiert gibt's web application 11.6 im app store ganz bestimmt
Boah man meine fresse alter microsoft wie kann man so eine scheiße fabrizieren
Das war abkriegen wieder, ey.
Alter.
Ich glaub es nicht.
Send Feedback.
Hier, Feedback senden wir jetzt.
Achtung.
Fickt euch.
Microsoft.
Microslop.
Explain in more detail.
Choose category.
Das geht eh nicht ohne.
Das geht ja eh nicht, weil ich nicht signed in bin.
Stimmt, ich brauche ja ein Microsoft Account natürlich.
Kann man das ausschalten?
Das braucht doch eh keiner.
Smart App Control.
Okay, off.
Bam.
Ist auch geil, ne?
Man kann es dann mal einschalten.
Jetzt muss ich Windows aninstallen.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Ich muss Windows aninstallen und neu installen,
dass ich es wieder einschalten könnte.
Und es ist geil.
Jetzt guckt mal.
Es gibt nicht mal eine Warnung,
dass man es nicht wieder einschalten kann.
Es gibt nicht mal eine Warnung.
Irgendjemand, der aus Versehen auf den Knopf drückt,
kann es nicht mehr einschalten ohne Reinstall.
Das ist so schlecht, Alter.
Das ist so absolut hardcore
Vibe-Codeder Bodensatz,
was Microsoft da wieder fabriziert hat.
Guckt euch diese Kacke
mal an, ey.
Gut, jetzt kann ich wenigstens meine eigene Anwendung wieder ausführen.
Das kann man wirklich nicht wieder einschalten, oder?
Das ist so schlecht, Alter.
Das ist so schlecht.
Ich weiß gar nicht...
Ich meine das jetzt wirklich ernst.
Ganz ernst gefragt.
Wie kann man sowas denn releasen?
Wie kann man das
ernsthaft auf die Menschheit loslassen?
Das müssen doch...
Mir fällt da gar keine Worte mehr ein.
Außer ganz
wüste Beleidigungen.
Was für ein Kackspast muss man eigentlich sein, um sowas zu releasen?
Das ist ja nicht mehr zu benutzen.
Gut, es juckt mich nicht, dass das aus ist.
Der ganze Scheiß bringt wahrscheinlich eh nichts.
Okay, wir fragen jetzt nochmal.
Ich hab noch eine Idee.
Turn smart app
back on
without
reinstalling Windows.
To turn back on without
modify the registry.
Das geht?
Es ist einfach ein stinknormaler
fucking registry hack und das geht nicht
übern...
Stimmt das, was sie da schreiben?
Also, seriously, geht das?
Moment, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Ich weiß, wir wollten uns heute eigentlich
Netzwerkkarten und Nasszeug angucken, aber das muss
jetzt erstmal sein.
Ach, by the way, wir haben heute mal zur Abwechslung wieder.
Hallo, Chat.
Ups.
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, wie schlecht das ist.
Guck mal, wie schlecht das ist, Alter.
Warum Minis Forum und kein Ich-hab-beides?
Ich hab beides
Ich hab drei nasses daheim
Die werden wir alle in den nächsten Streams ausprobieren
Und gucken, was das Beste ist
Wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, jetzt followen
Normalerweise rage ich nicht so rum
Also, das hält sich in Grenzen
Aber das ist ja heute wieder absolut
Ich rage nur rum, wenn es gerechtfertigt ist
Und es ist gerechtfertigt
Guckte mal, seht ihr mal
Alter, welcher Vibe-Coding-Depp
Hat sich das wieder ausgedacht
Beim Microslop
Guckt euch das mal an
Guck mal, es gab hier früher wenigstens noch einen Hinweis.
Seht ihr das?
Es gab hier früher noch einen Hinweis.
Ey, meint ihr, meint ihr, das ist einfach...
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Theme.
Sekunde, Sekunde, warte mal.
Ähm...
Wie macht man überhaupt das Light-Theme an?
Das ist bestimmt eine Schrift.
Ähm...
Okay, Light-Mode.
Ne, ne, die Schrift gibt es nirgendwo
Haha, es ist so schlecht
Alter, es ist so schlecht
Guck mal, früher
Ich mein, so ein Hinweis
Achtung, du kannst es nicht wieder einschalten
Wenn du deaktivierst
Brauch man nicht, braucht man nicht
Wird einfach ausgeblendet
Es gibt nicht mal einen Warnhinweis
Dass das der Fall ist
Also ich wusste es ja
Ich hab es ja im Internet gelesen vorher
Aber ansonsten jemand, der einfach mal draufklickt
Okay, jetzt gucken wir, wie man es wieder einschaltet
Okay
Das ist wirklich so ein Registry-Hack
Wenn man off auswählt, passiert es ohne Warnung
Ja, das einzige, was passiert, ist, dass du dein Admin-Passwort eintippen musst
Das ist aber keine Warnung, wo jetzt irgendwie drin steht
Achtung, du kannst es nicht wieder einschalten
Du musst für jeden Scheiß, ohne dass dein Admin-Passwort eingeht
Nein, du kannst dir das im Stream angucken.
Okay, ich scroll mal kurz ein bisschen vor.
Obviously, natürlich, natürlich ist das der Registry Key.
Welcher Registry Key sollte es auch sonst sein?
Mach dein Windows Update, dann geht es auch ohne Rack Edit?
Wirklich? Kam das jetzt neu dabei oder was?
sicher wie kommst du drauf ist wirklich so ja warum willst du den dreck wieder einschalten
naja an sich ist es ja kein schlechtes feature der witz ist nur dass das meine eigene anwendung
geblockt hat die ich selbst programmiert habe weil sie nicht gescheit ist die können nicht
bei microsoft maler vielleicht lasse ich doch einfach wirklich aus okay man kann es easy mit
im Registry Hack wieder einschalten.
Was habe ich denn noch für Sachen? Ausstehen?
Hier, Update. Ja, ein paar Sachen habe ich noch
ausstehen. Sieht man das nicht hier, welche Updates
noch aus... Ach, whatever.
Windows. Leck mich, Windows. Ich habe keinen Bock.
Ich lasse das jetzt einfach.
Oh, was für eine Aufregung
jetzt schon wieder, ey.
Nach dem Update ist das wieder an.
Wieso? Ist das...
Ist das Update 26H1 oder was?
Ich denke, es gibt nur noch 26H2.
Warum mein Rechner so schnell ist, wenn ich so viele Tabs aufhabe?
Das sind doch noch nicht mal viele Tabs.
Du hast nicht gesehen, wie das aussah, als ich ein paar Jahre gestreamt habe und nie meinen Browser neu gestartet habe.
Das ist ja nichts dagegen.
Das sind ja vielleicht 30 Tabs, wenn es hochkommt.
Das ist ja nichts.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem, wenn du ordentlich RAM hast
Und selbst, du brauchst noch nicht mal ordentlich RAM
Das wird ja mittlerweile im Hintergrund sogar
Gefri... also, also
Quasi suspended
Das geht bei dir auch
Also, wenn du ordentlich einen Rechner hast, ist das kein Problem
Ist klar, also hast du andere Probleme
Wenn die paar Tabs deinen Rechner langsam machen
Dann stimmt irgendwas anderes nicht
Bei dir ist alles 100 mal schneller
Ja, hast du irgendeinen Mist installiert?
Windows Tuning
Utilities oder irgendwie so ein Kram
Also ich hab
Mein Rechner ist auch schon 3 Jahre alt mittlerweile wieder
Also ich hab ne
13.900k
Ne 4090, das aber nichts mit meiner
Windows Geschwindigkeit zu tun hat und 64g
Die ich auch nicht brauche
Also deiner ist wahrscheinlich sogar
Schneller als meiner
Dann weiß ich nicht
Aber ich kenn mich mit Windows ähnlich aus
So, Chat, Chat
Ich muss mich jetzt erstmal wieder abregen
Von dem Microsoft-Kram, ey
Monk HW, Alter
Monk HW
Ja, ist drei Jahre her, ne
Ende 2022
habe ich den Rechner gekauft.
Ich mache mal OS-Update.
OS-Update ist immer nicht verkehrt.
OS-Update
beruhigt die Nerven.
Ich habe auch schon meine Tabletten genommen
zum Beruhigen. Alles Gute.
Nur Probleme gehabt mit SSD, CPU und Mainboard
Das war ja auch so ziemlich die schlechteste
Hardwarequalität, die ich seit
Generationen gesehen hab
Muss ich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
Warte mal, ich hab doch hier irgendwo
Ah, schau mal
Hier, guck mal
Also
Fangen wir mal an
Netzteil funktioniert
Wasserkühler funktioniert
Gehäuse funktioniert
Diese komische Platte funktioniert
Mainboard funktioniert
Grafikkarte hätte theoretisch anfangen können zu brennen
So, erstes großes Problem. Mit dem Originaladapter hätte die Grafikkarte bzw. eigentlich der Stecker hätte anfangen können zu brennen. Nice, super Qualität, tolle Nvidia, ist übrigens immer noch angeblich so.
Die CPU-Platte
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr
Aber das hat ein paar Grad kühler
Sollte es ein paar Grad kühler machen
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr
Warum ich das habe
Ich habe keinen Schimmer mehr
Chat, warum habe ich das?
Ich weiß es nicht
Warum habe ich das nochmal?
Das ist vom Auer
Der Auer kennt sich aus
Der 8 Auer
Der Bauer kennt sich aus.
Das kann nicht schlecht sein.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall, dass es ein bisschen kühler geblieben ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was das eigentlich genau macht, um ehrlich zu sein.
Dass der Kühler gleichmäßig auf die CPU drückt.
Okay.
Ja, mittlerweile.
Ich habe...
Guck mal.
Ich habe so viel weniger bezahlt.
Plus 334.
Zumindest.
Also, nur mal so.
Nur mal so hier.
Qualität.
Qualität, ne?
Grafikkarte.
Stecker hätte anfangen können zu brennen
Hier, krasser Overclock
Poggers RAM mit super Timing
Schafft seinen Takt nicht
Ich hab den nicht mehr auf 6400 laufen
Gab ab und zu random Blue Screens
So einmal in der Woche oder so
Seitdem nie wieder
Krasser Overclocker
Poggers RAM hat sich nicht gelohnt
Packt den Takt nicht, geil
Zweite Hardware Problem
CPU
Das hat ja wahrscheinlich noch jeder im Kopf
Diese CPU Generation
die hatte da ist irgendwie spannung geleakt und hat die haltbarkeit drastisch reduziert das ist
da wo ganz viele leute random plus screens gekriegt haben die ihren rechner viel belastet
haben habe ich zum glück nicht muss 5 580 mal bios patchen und so bis das behoben ist und
sie noch richtig behoben hat wer die dritte dritte hardware dritte hardware im arsch ja
nächstes nächstes samsung ssd firma mit der die ausgeliefert wurde hatte wir level probleme und
hat super schnell verschleißt für das Hardware-Problem.
Man muss sich mal überlegen,
die Grafikkarte, der RAM, die CPU
und die SSD. Man könnte quasi
sagen, vielleicht neben dem Mainboard,
die vier wichtigsten Komponenten
in meinem PC waren im Arsch.
Was für eine Scheiß-Qualität.
Stellt euch das mal vor
bei einem 5000 Euro Rechner.
Das kann man sich doch, das kann man sich ja ausmalen, oder?
Und dazu kommt,
dass Microsoft mir jetzt verbietet, meine eigene
Programme auszuführen.
Also ganz ehrlich, das ist richtig für den Arsch
gerade, PC-Plattformen so.
Auch von den Preisen her,
ganz schlimm.
Kann auch am Mainboard liegen.
Naja, also das Mainboard
ist ein extra für Gaming
POC Elite AX
was auch immer. Das bietet sogar
das direkt an, dass du die
XMP-Profile und so gleich laden kannst
für den RAM und alles. Also, das liegt nicht am Mainboard,
das liegt am RAM.
Spulenfieten bin ich auch sehr
empfindlich dagegen. Hatte ich in letzter Zeit glücklicherweise
keine Probleme mit.
Würdest du Wasserkühlung statt Luftkühlung empfehlen? Ganz ehrlich,
im Nachhinein betrachtet,
hätte ich es wahrscheinlich nicht gebraucht,
weil
so wenig, wie ich den Rechner wirklich
komplett auslaste, hätte es wahrscheinlich
die Luftkühlung auch getan.
Und da, wo ich ihn auslaste,
wäre es wahrscheinlich mit Luftkühlung auch
okay gewesen. Also,
muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich muss aber sagen, jetzt so mal
rückblickend drei Jahre, ich hatte
absolut zero,
null, wirklich komplett null Probleme
mit dieser Wasserkühlung.
Also, das kann ich empfehlen.
Gibt es bestimmt was Neueres von. Überhaupt kein Ding.
Super Teil. Funzt.
Macht kühl. Keine Probleme.
Und es ist leise, es ist leise, ja, also Kühler drehen ja auch nur langsam, es ist leise
Wenn das Ding aber mal richtig, wenn das Ding mal richtig hoch dreht, ja, dann hörst du schon ordentlich, ja
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwas, irgendwas spiele hier und so einstelle, dass es ordentlich FPS gibt
Dann, also dass die Grafikkarte auch schön schafft, dann dreht der Rechner schon ordentlich hoch
Aber da habe ich eben mein Headset auf, sonst stört es mich nicht weiter
So, ich wollte noch irgendeine Frage beantworten, ich habe es hier, warte mal, lass mich mal kurz gucken
Was ist denn mit dem Uclean DXP, das habe ich ja, das habe ich unten im Flur stehen
Ich sag gleich was zu den Nasses.
Hier wurde ich aufgeregt.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Also, jetzt kommen wir mal zum Nass.
Ich hab mir drei Nasses bestellt.
Mehr oder weniger
by accident.
Ich hab mir als erstes
einen U-Cream 4800 Plus bestellt.
Das Ding hier.
Da habe ich auch ein paar Wochen
ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt.
Naja, ein paar Wochen ist vielleicht übertrieben.
Zwei Wochen oder so. Wann habe ich erzählt, dass das angekommen ist?
Das ist noch nicht so lange her.
Das ist aber zwei, drei Wochen oder so.
Da habe ich ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt.
War ich eigentlich auch ganz zufrieden.
Habe ich mir auch gedacht,
ja, könnte man.
Es gab so ein paar Sachen, da war ich nicht so ganz happy mit.
Aber ich habe mir so gedacht, ja, könnte man.
Kann man schon verwenden.
der stromverbrauch war mir vielleicht ein bisschen hoch also man kriegt das
man kriegt das schon unter 20 watt aber nicht so nicht viel und gerade wenn er
auch ein bisschen was drin ist also ja also ein pc slot hätte ich vielleicht
auch noch gerne gehabt und ganz ehrlich bisschen mehr cpu leistung hätte auch
sein können also war ich jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig zufrieden aber sagen
wir mal zu 90 prozent ist das eigentlich eine gute plattform gewesen wollen wie
die box abscription einfach das ganz ganz ganz gute plattform so und dann habe
gelesen dass es bei ukraine jetzt das gleiche nach nochmal gibt nur in der pro variante die
pro variante hat eine ein performance core mehr die alte hatte vier efficiency kurs ein
performance core und der performance core kann halber turning also hattest du sechs virtuelle
kerne jetzt hast du sechs echte kerne vier efficiency course 2 performance
course mit hyperthreading was dann glaube ich sieben kerne macht also virtuelle kerne
die acht oder
8 8 virtuelle kerne macht
so und das ding habe ich mir dann auch bestellt weil ich mir gedacht habe ganz ehrlich das gibt
es ja auch hier mit voucher und bonus code und so kriegst du das für unter unter also das gibt
noch einen extra Code, den du eingeben kannst,
wenn man sich das YouTube-Video von denen angeguckt hat.
Und man kriegt das, wenn man es bestellt,
für, würde ich sagen, 670
oder sowas. So, und dann,
und dann,
als das schon auf dem Weg war,
das wurde jetzt erst verschickt vor zwei, drei Tagen,
das ist erst gestern angekommen, als das
auf dem Weg war, hat Minis Forum
auch ein neues NAS vorgestellt.
Nämlich
das N5R.
Und das habe ich mir
Das ist übrigens sogar noch günstiger.
Und das habe ich mir angeguckt und habe mir das von den Hardware-Specs mal angeguckt.
Und habe mir gedacht, das ist eigentlich wirklich die perfekte, also zumindest die beste Nass-Plattform, die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Und dann habe ich mir das Ding auch noch bestellt.
Jetzt habe ich drei Nasses daheim.
Zwei davon, okay.
Das eine kann ich glaube ich nicht mehr zurückschicken, weil ich schon, ah, könnte knapp hinhauen vielleicht.
Weil ich es vielleicht schon zu lange da habe.
Aber eins schicke ich auf jeden Fall zurück.
ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich das hier weil von den specs muss ich sagen von den specs finde ich
das ding hier eigentlich am besten jemand im chat hat er letztens geschrieben hat das mini forum pro
das mini forum pro wird habe ich gelesen auf reddit gerade nicht mehr hergestellt weil die probleme
mit ihrem sata controller haben was langfristig zu data corruption führt das schlecht das ding
einen anderen sata controller das ding ist wirklich gute auf dem papier auf dem papier
hier ja bei the way chat bei the way hier hier steht da das da das da ist es
man sieht nicht wirklich viel aber ich zeige euch gleich was drin ist
macht von der verarbeitung her einen guten eindruck vorne haste 5 1 schiebe
anstatt 4 beim juli haste glaube ich nur 4 aber das coole ist also warum ich
finde dass das eine wirklich gute plattform ist wir gucken uns auch
gleich zusammen an bevor wir dann die netzwerkkarte flächen wo ich das
hinkriegt.
Also, 5 HDDs
finde ich perfekte Kombi,
weil, warum? Das bietet
dir die Möglichkeit, einen RAID
5 zu machen mit 3 Platten. Mit 3 Platten
ist ein RAID 5 gerade noch so okay.
Ja, mit 3 großen Platten ist ein RAID
5 gerade noch so okay, kann man machen.
Plus noch ein Mirror mit SSDs.
Könnte man machen, zum Beispiel. Ja, oder
anderweitig bestückt.
Oder aber, man könnte 5 Platten
reinmachen mit einem RAID 6. Auch nicht
verkehrt. 4 Platten mit einem RAID 6
finde ich irgendwie doof, dann gleich 5.
Also das bietet mir, finde ich,
flexiblere Möglichkeiten. Dazu ist,
dazu kommt,
dass du intern
drei gut zugängliche
NVMe-Slots hast.
Also hier kannst du intern, da haben die kein Bild,
ich muss euch, ich zeige euch das gleich
in der Kamera, ja.
Du hast drei gut zugängliche NVMe-Slots,
da kriegt man
eine Unraid drauf, klar. Für Unraid
gibt es was noch viel besseres. Abriss Johnny,
wenn ich das gleich zeige, erinnere mich nochmal
dran im Chat, dass ich das nicht vergesse.
Ich zeige dir was richtig cooles für
Unraid bei dem Ding. Wo ich mir auch
ganz kurz überlegt habe,
ob ich mir nicht doch noch wieder Unraid
installiere. Erinnere mich gleich nochmal dran, wenn wir uns das angucken.
Genau. 10 Gig,
5 Gig Netzwerk
Ports.
So, genau. Also.
Und das Coole ist, es hat eine
8 Kern CPU. Ein AMD Ryzen
7. Das ist ohne Scheiß
vom preis her von dem was es hat was es kann und alles finde ich das besser als
das ukraine ist verbraucht sogar weniger strom ich habe es mal kurz komplett leer
beide geräte angeschlossen also dass ukraine das verbraucht ohne bios settings
knapp über 20 watt idle mit bios settings 18 oder so 19 20 und das hier
verbraucht unbestückt
Eidel 11.
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen mehr bestückt.
Also das ist schon besser. Und jetzt kommt absolutes
Premium-Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das da reingekriegt haben,
weil von der Größe her ist es kein
allzu großer Unterschied. Das Minis-Form
ist vielleicht minimal größer. Aber jetzt kommt
das Beste.
Was stellst du in den Bios ein für weniger Verbrauch?
Du meinst auf dem U-Creen?
Moment. Das habe ich aus dem Reddit-Thread.
Ähm.
Das da.
So, gehen wir nicht auf den Sackreddit hier mit Übersetzung.
Ich habe das anhand von diesem Reddit-Thread eingestellt.
Und das hat tatsächlich ein paar Watt gebracht.
Hast du noch RAM?
Ja, ich habe noch RAM.
Ich habe noch RAM.
Ich habe mir damals ein Beelink CR7 gekauft.
Da.
und da damals als es günstig war nur 32 g gramm kannst du kurz link in chat post ja kann ich
machen das hat ein paar watt reduziert ob langfristige seiten effekte hat mit dem ganzen
pc express power saving kann ich aber nicht sagen so und jetzt kommt das absolut beste an dem dinge
sind zwei coole sachen das hat einen okulink port das heißt man kann wenn man es extrem übertreiben
will, kann man da eine PCI-Express-Grafikkarte dran machen.
Das heißt, wenn sich irgendjemand lokalen AI-Kram da noch irgendwie dran flanschen will,
würde es theoretisch funktionieren.
So, aber jetzt kommt das, finde ich, Beste an dem Ding noch zusätzlich.
Die haben doch in der Tat...
die machen die da gar keine werbung für oder was
okay whatever die machen hier die haben den pc express slot trainer noch eingebaut was
ein pc express lot low profile das ist ohne scheiß die beste home lab das schrägstrich
Virtualisierung, Container, Plattform,
die ich bisher so out of the box gesehen
habe.
Wer macht denn lokale KI
auf seinem NAS? Es gibt viele Leute, die
lokale KI machen.
Warum sollte man es nicht auf dem NAS machen, wenn du einen
Okulink hast und eine Grafikkarte reinpappen kannst?
Dein NAS läuft 24-7.
Wenn du da beispielsweise sowas drauflaufen lässt
wie Paperless und willst
eine lokale KI
laufen haben, die deine Dokumente
immer klassifiziert und richtig taggt und sowas.
Warum nicht? Warum nicht? Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen, das Ding dürfte auch schnell genug sein mit 32 GB RAM. Das ein oder andere, die Kiste muss doch auch die Leistung bereitstellen.
naja macht's doch
das Ding ist nicht schlecht
das Ding hat einen 8 Kern
8 Kern Ryzen
packt genug NVMe SSDs
packt genug RAM
und hat einen PCI Express Slot für eine Grafikkarte
also
einen Oculink Port für eine Grafikkarte
für LLMs sollte es nicht, klar reicht es
du brauchst
Grafikkarten und du brauchst Grafikkarten Speicher
wenn du schnell lokale LLMs
haben willst, dann flutscht das
und wenn du nur RAM und
SSD hast, geht es auch noch halbwegs, aber halt
deutlich langsamer. Aber für so Sachen wie
Paperless AI, würde es sogar auch
ganz ohne Grafikkarte tun.
Da reicht ja, wenn du ordentlich RAM hast,
lässt du ein lokales Model laufen.
Selbst wenn das bloß keine Ahnung, 6 Tokens
die Sekunde schafft, ist ja egal.
Dann braucht es klassifizieren vom Dokument halt mal
kurz. Juckt ja nicht
weiter. Das werde ich
auf jeden Fall auch ausprobieren.
So Chat, nachdem ich mich jetzt so
hier reingesteigert habe, zeige ich euch das
Teil mal. Ich kann euch, ich bin gerade
am Umbauen hier.
Also, das was ihr hier seht, ist immer noch
der alte Tisch.
Ich habe mir mittlerweile
einen neuen Tisch gekauft, der geht dann hier so quasi
so komplett.
Das ist so ein ganz kleiner Tisch. Also alles was
ihr hier seht, das ist quasi schon mehr oder weniger der
ganze Tisch, den ihr hier seht.
Und ich habe mir einen neuen Tisch gekauft, der geht dann
hier eineinhalb Meter an der Wand
lang.
Ich mache mal kurz hier den Kram ab.
weil ganz ehrlich, das ist zu klein, das kann ich euch jetzt nicht richtig zeigen,
ich muss mal den Computer da rausholen, also hier vorne sieht man eigentlich nur ganz gut,
5 Bayonets, USB, C, USB und ein paar LEDs, also das ist jetzt nicht so spannend,
hinten können wir uns kurz angucken, wobei, das gucken wir uns nicht an, das zeige ich euch gleich,
ich hole jetzt mal den Computer raus, dieses Ding hier, da unten, was ihr hier seht,
Und da, wo die Status-LEDs dran sind, da hier, guckt mal, das kann man rausziehen.
Schaut mal, da kommt jetzt der Computer quasi raus.
Das mache ich mal kurz und stelle das Nass auf die Erde.
Dann kann ich euch das nämlich besser zeigen, weil das Nass an sich, das Case ist jetzt nicht so wirklich spannend.
So, da ist das Teil.
Also
Gucken wir mal rein
Ehrlich gesagt
So einen großartigen Nährwert, dass wir da jetzt reingucken
Hat das nicht, aber ich wollte mal wieder hier mein Kamerasetup testen
Ob noch alles funktioniert
Wobei ist aber immer ganz cool zu sehen
Also hier haben wir
Komm wir schrauben das mal
Wir schrauben das mal auf, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind
Sieht man alles gescheit?
Ja, ich denke schon
Warte mal, ein bisschen hier hin
Es ist zwar wackelig, aber
Wartet mal
Ist zwar wackelig, aber ich glaube, hier ist es besser, wenn man das so drunter sieht.
Licht und so müsste auch gut passen, denke ich.
Ich habe hier mein Ringlight an.
Man könnte es...
Chat, was haltet ihr denn davon?
Ein Ticken heller könnte man es noch machen, oder?
Ein Ticken heller könnte man es, glaube ich, noch machen.
Wartet mal.
Wie geht das?
äh
Chat?
Ein Ticken heller noch, ha?
Base liegt in der Schraube, ja.
ähm
Dann wird es eher milchiger, wenn ich das so mache
Das ist auch nichts
Ach, ich habe auch das falsche
Ich habe auch das falsche genommen
Ich muss Gamma
Ja, so ist besser, ne?
So ein bisschen hier Gamma anheben
Ich glaube, das ist besser.
Das sieht zwar vielleicht nicht mehr so kontrastreich aus,
aber man erkennt es.
So ist, glaube ich, gut.
So ist gut.
So lassen wir das.
Also, ich mache das mal kurz auf.
Sekunde, Leute.
Übrigens, war mal keine Werbung.
Ich werde nicht gesponsert oder so.
Soll ich euch mal gerade meine zwei Lieblings-
und mit Abstand meistbenutzten Werkzeuge zeigen?
Eine habe ich schon lang.
Andere habe ich noch nicht lang, feiere ich aber richtig.
Warum flashst du die Netzwerkkarte? Wäre ich gleich was zu erzählen.
Feiere ich aber richtig, wenn ich irgendwas machen muss, wenn irgendwo die Dunstabzugshaube abgemacht werden muss oder sonst was.
Zwei Sachen, die nehme ich immer mit und damit kommst du zu 80% durch.
Ja.
Das ist einmal hier.
Ich zeige euch die zwei Dinger.
Ich mache mal weg.
Mein Toilett.
Ich habe mich gerade selbst gemutet.
Ich dab.
Also.
Hier.
Die zwei Dinger.
Abschaut meine Lieblings...
zwei Lieblingssachen, die ich auch total oft verwende
und so standardmäßig
immer mitnehme. Ich habe einmal hier
meinen PB Swiss.
Unsinnig teuer.
Muss man nicht den kaufen, aber den finde ich nice.
Im Prinzip
ein Bit-Halter.
So ein Schraubendreher, ein Bit-Halter mit Ratschen-Funktion.
Kann man in beide Seiten
machen, auf- und zuschrauben.
Ja.
Parkside macht es auch.
Und das Coole ist, der hat hier immer
So die meistbenutzten Bits hast du hier hinten im Griff drin.
Ansonsten hat es eine sehr feinteilige Ratsche.
Also die merkst du kaum, wackelt auch nichts.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ordentliche Qualität.
Damit kommst du zu 90% bei Schrauben aus.
Und dann habe ich noch hier eine Multifunktionszange.
Die finde ich auch mega nice.
Du kannst einmal hier vorne so spitzzangenmäßig kannst du was halten hier unten.
Dann hast du hier noch, kannst du schrauben.
Guck, wenn das hier jetzt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, das ist eine Schraube, die kannst du quasi hier so greifen und dann drehen.
Dann hast du, falls du irgendwelche Ader-Endhülsen krimpen musst oder so, mache ich nicht.
Ich gehe nicht an 230 Volt dran, sage ich euch gleich.
Kannst du aber theoretisch hier, kannst du krimpen.
Warte mal, die Kamera checkt es wieder nicht.
Warte mal, wir machen das mal anders.
Sekunde.
aha so ist noch besser guck mal da hier kannst du krimpen dran zack zack
kannst du krimpen hier kannst du kabel abisolieren mit 0,7 mm 1,5 mm 2,5 mm ich
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich mal irgendwie gerade was da habe.
Oh.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwie so ein Teil.
Ähm.
Hier hast du einen Kabel, äh, einen Seitenschneider.
Und hier oben, hier oben, seht ihr das Loch?
Hier oben kannst du schrauben und Nägel kürzen mit.
Dann hast du hier unten einmal abgerundet.
da kannst du, wenn du Drähte hast oder so, kannst du
quasi die Drähte drüber machen und quasi
schon mal biegen.
Und hier unten
ist ein bisschen scharfkantig. Da kannst du
irgendwas entgraden mit. Also richtig
nice. Also finde ich top.
Finde ich wirklich top.
Deine Finger sind ja richtig dünn.
Das stimmt. Mittlerweile schon. Ich habe noch 25 Kilo
abgenommen.
Mal gucken
Achso und was auch mega ist
Guckt mal
Seht ihr das da?
Da hast du so eine Feder drin
Manche Leute
Mögen es wenn die Zange so
Quasi freigängig ist so wie hier
Aber man kann das auch hier weg machen
Guck wenn man das hier weg macht dann
Oh shit
Close Leute
Ich hätte fast mein Stromkabel
Durchgeschnitten
Hier vorne hängt nämlich eins
So, und
Jetzt geht das, guck, jetzt geht das von alleine
Von alleine auf
Darum machen wir das gerade mal wieder rückgängig
Dass man ein bisschen was sieht
Guck hier, hier vorne hätte ich fast durchgeschnitten
Aber da hätte ich bis hierhin gehen müssen
Zum Durchschneiden
So, schneiden wir das hier mal durch
Und mal gucken, ich hab noch nie so ein kleines
Kabel, ehrlich gesagt, probiert hier mit
Ähm, aber
Ne, ach warte mal, ich mach's ja auch falsch rum
Nee, das geht nicht richtig.
Das ist ein Tick...
Das ist ein Tick zu klein.
Das Funzen ist nicht richtig hier.
Das ist ein bisschen zu klein.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe das auch noch nie benutzt zum Abisolieren.
Zum Abisolieren habe ich immer noch hier diese...
Den hier.
Beste.
der ist top zum abisolieren.
Macht man einfach hier rein
und dann, zack
und fertig, abisoliert.
Aber wenn man
mal keinen abisolierten Zangen so dabei hat,
dann ist das hier auch gar nicht
verkehrt. Also das Ding
finde ich wirklich mega nice.
Nennt sich
wie H1 in 9,
1 in 10
Zange oder so.
1 in 8 Zange.
1 in 8 Zange nennt sich das.
Ja.
So.
Das war jetzt etwas sidetracked.
Werkzeugstilz.
Aber das finde ich mega nice.
Das finde ich top.
So.
Dauerwerbesendung.
Ja.
Und den hier benutze ich auch gern.
Aber die Bits sind ein bisschen groß.
Für das was wir jetzt hier schrauben wollen.
Weil eigentlich wollen wir ans NAS dran.
NAS Champ.
Ähm, hab ich irgendwas, wo man das hier drauflegen kann, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen ebener ist?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal.
Nehmen wir mal hier irgendwie einen Schrauber.
Und machen mal hier die Schrauben raus.
Das passt nicht.
Sackt schon wieder.
Oh, geht das schwer.
Monke ist, ich hab das letzte Mal ein bisschen zu fest zugemacht.
So.
also was haben wir auf der seite
so auf der seite aber einmal lüfter unter drunter haben wir drei ssd steckplätze
wie man hier schön sieht.
SSD Champ.
Also.
Wir haben hier
das kommt übrigens nicht mit hier.
Das habe ich dran gebastelt.
Den Passivkühler an die SSDs.
Das ist nicht dabei.
Das hier ist eine
Samsung 99 Pro
2TB glaube ich und das ist eine
samsung 19 pro 1 terabyte übrigens diese dieses kit dieses passiv cooler kit das
kostet plus acht euro oder sowas bei amazon für zwei das kann man sich mal
gönnen auch mal ab und zu machen und das hier
wird mitgeliefert das ist eine 24 gig mit mini ssd nvm ssd die kann man aber
gut für das betriebssystem zum beispiel verwenden
Was hast du dann vor, an dem Nass physisch zu machen?
Wie?
Netzwerkkarte einbauen, höchstens.
Netz habe ich schon gemacht, Netzwerkkarte ist schon eingebaut.
Und hier halt SSDs rein, ja.
Achso, guck mal, der checkt den Fokus wieder nicht richtig.
Du sollst nicht...
Du sollst nicht auf den Lüfter fokussieren, du sollst hierhin fokussieren, Kamera.
Da, da sollst du hin fokussieren.
Guck mal, der denkt, es ist viel wichtiger, dass dieser Lüfter, der Lüfter muss unbedingt ganz furchtbar scharf sein.
Lüfter ist besser, den muss der unbedingt reinzoomen, ja.
So, also, wer sich jetzt fragt, warum ist das eine 2TB SSD und eine 1TB SSD?
Das ist ganz einfach, weil ich die noch da hatte.
Irgendwo hier habe ich auch, wenn ich Pech habe, liegt es hier unten drunter.
Hm, oder auch nicht. Ah, da hinten liegt es, da hinten liegt es.
Wir könnten bei der Gelegenheit, wenn wir es jetzt gerade schon nochmal aufhaben,
ich habe auch noch eine alte, äh, hier, guckt mal.
Eine alte 970 Evo habe ich hier noch am Start.
Die könnte man theoretisch reinbauen, weil ganz ehrlich,
dieses eingebaute 64-Gig-Ding,
na, ich weiß ja nicht.
Ob das so geil ist.
So, also der Grund ist,
einfach nur, weil ich das schon hatte und weil SSDs
schweineteuer sind.
Deswegen habe ich mir so gedacht,
warum soll ich mir neue SSDs kaufen,
wenn ich schon zwei Stück da habe.
Die sind ja auch schnell genug.
Also, die Dinger, die 990 Pros, äh, nicht 990 Pros, die, ist das ein U-Creen-NAS? Das ist nicht das U-Creen-NAS, das U-Creen-NAS, das U-Creen-NAS, Sekunde, das U-Creen-NAS ist hier, da, U-Creen, guck, da hast du, da ist das D-Einschub bei U-Creen, das ist das U-Creen-NAS, das ist Minisforum, das ist das Minisforum N5R,
was ich von der Plattform her
tatsächlich besser finde als das Ugreen.
Aber wir werden das alles ausprobieren.
79 Evos sind legendär.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja.
By the way,
wie würde man die SSD hier überhaupt reinmachen?
Die ist überhaupt kein
kein, äh, ne?
Kein Dings. Wie heißt denn das? Auflage.
Guck mal.
Äh.
Wait a minute.
Ja doch, das würde passen.
Da sind bestimmt noch welche in der Tüte.
Hier.
Da hier.
Hier hinten.
So.
Das lassen wir jetzt aber erstmal so.
Jetzt schauen wir mal wieder zu an der Stelle.
Ach ja, auch noch eine coole Sache.
Man hat es glaube ich schon gesehen.
Abriss Johnny, bist du noch am Start?
Ich wollte dir was richtig Nices doch noch für Unraid zeigen.
Ich weiß nicht, sieht es jemand zufällig schon was Nices für Unraid?
Chat, wer ist High IQ und hat es schon erkannt?
Man sieht es, man sieht es im Bild.
Gerade so.
Internal USB.
Genau.
Gucke mal, was es hier hinten gibt.
Siehst du das?
Ein internen USB 3.0 Anschluss.
Das ist natürlich optimal für Unraid.
Da kannst du nämlich deinen Android-Stick hier entnehmen.
Nimmst du hier so einen Teil da, ja.
Zack.
Kommt mal ein bisschen schlecht ran, aber im Großen und Ganzen.
Döpfelst du rein und hast hier deinen Android-Stick drauf.
Ist das nicht nice?
Viel besser als irgendwie hinten am Gehäuse oder so.
Du kannst dir auch so einen ganz kleinen USB-Stick holen, der dann da halb drinnen verschwindet oder so.
Aber du hast einen internalen USB.
Was natürlich super für Unraid ist, weil Unraid wird über USB gebootet.
Ja, Moment, Moment. Das wird nicht nur einfach über USB gebootet. Es geht nicht anders.
Ich glaube, es gab jetzt mal Diskussion, ob Unraid nicht auch normale Plattendisks unterstützen will.
Aber soweit ich weiß, aktuell ist es so, Unraid braucht zwingend einen USB-Stick.
Und Anest funzt es nicht.
was ist eigentlich besser android oder proxmox ganz ehrlich ich glaube es kommt ein bisschen
darauf an weil ich bin ja ich habe auch proxmox werden wir zwar hier auf dem nassen ist aber
kenne ich mich auch nicht so großartig mit aus es hängt ein bisschen davon ab wo dein schwerpunkt
drauf liegt man könnte sie auch erweitern android proxmox open media world schulers oder was auch
immer es kommt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen drauf an was du für einen schwerpunkt legt ja wenn es
die hauptsächlich darum geht virtualisierung kvm paar container dann ist box box gut wenn es dir
eher geht um netzwerk storage mit ein bisschen docker container dabei dann ist anwalt super
wenn es hier hauptsächlich um netzwerk storage geht und zfs dann ist wahrscheinlich tun das
besser.
Open Media Vault,
weiß ich nicht, wann das besser ist.
Ich mag Open Media Vault
mittlerweile übrigens. Also nicht, dass das
jetzt irgendwie als
Open Media Vault Flame
gedeutet wird oder so.
Ja. Aber das ist zumindest
sehr nice, dass es hier einen internen
USB
A ist das glaube ich, ne?
USB A Stecker gibt. Also das
ist top für
Unraid.
So, jetzt schrauben wir das mal kurz wieder zusammen.
Weil ich kenne mich schon, wenn ich das jetzt nicht wieder
festschraube, dann bleibe ich irgendwie
dran hängen und reiße den Lüfter ab oder sowas.
Das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Machen wir mal wieder dicht hier.
Die Schraube
geht ein bisschen schwer hier oben an der Ecke. Keine Ahnung
warum.
So, und dann zeige ich euch die andere Seite, wo es den PCI Express Slot gibt.
Moment, wollte ich nicht die, wollte ich nicht die, ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Ich habe jetzt auch gar keinen Passivkühler mehr da, ich lasse die Original SSD da drin, die ist ja nur für Systeminstallation, da passt das.
So, gucken wir uns die andere Seite an.
Da haben wir eine Netzwerkkarte.
Und um die Netzwerkkarte geht es zumindest teilweise heute.
Ich habe nämlich noch eine alte 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte am Start.
Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, warum will der Max da unbedingt nochmal 10-Gig dran?
Und das hat zwei Gründe.
Erstens habe ich gelesen, das müssen wir noch ausprobieren,
habe ich gelesen, dass die
Onboard
10 Gig Karte oder die
hier, ich weiß es gar nicht, welches von beiden ist
steht das dran?
Ich glaube es steht nicht mal dran, welche davon
das jetzt, steht das? Chat?
Das steht nicht dran, oder?
Also ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was hier von die
10 Gig Karte ist. Ich habe gelesen, der
Linux Treiber
ist wohl noch recht neu und nicht so geil
und das zweite
ist
Sfp plus ist in der Regel deutlich stromsparender als rj45 Kupfer, und ich wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren, ob das damit funzt.
Wenn, also wir müssen das beides ausprobieren, wir gucken dann mal Stromverbrauch und gucken mal was denn, wie beide Netzwerkkarten performen
Ganz im Ernst, wenn die Netzwerkkarte hier ordentliche Speed-Sachen hinkriegt unter Linux
Es gibt zum Beispiel einen Bug, den habe ich gelesen, es gibt einen Bug für den Linux-Treiber
Manchmal kann es passieren, dass nach dem Standby oder dem Reboot Linux die Netzwerkkarte nicht erkennt
Dann muss man wirklich den Stecker komplett rausziehen und wieder reinmachen, dass es dann funktioniert
Das sind so Sachen, die brauche ich natürlich jetzt bei einem NAS nicht unbedingt.
Gibt es Gründe für ein N5R?
Ja, das wird sich jetzt zeigen, was die beste Plattform ist.
Mein...
Ugreen NAS...
...ist ja hier.
Ist ja auch am Start.
Müssen wir alles ausprobieren.
und die Pro-Variante steht unten im Flur noch.
Aber ich mach nicht
krasses Pepo-Burn-Money, ich schick
davon auch wieder was zurück. Genau,
das heißt, wir haben jetzt hier dran
2x 10GB, 1x
SFP+, 10GB, 10GB
ähm
ja, 10GB RJ45
und 5GB RJ45.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, und hier ist übrigens
da, ist übrigens der
Wenn man den RAM einbauen will, muss man diesen komischen Kühler da runter machen.
Ich vermute mal, hier drunter irgendwo ist GPU und CPU.
Habe ich mir jetzt nicht näher angeguckt.
Man kann hier oben abmachen und aufmachen.
Und dann muss man auch aufmachen, dass man den RAM dran hat.
Mir persönlich wäre es fast lieber gewesen, sie hätten das irgendwie hierhin gepappt, den RAM.
Dann kommst du nämlich besser dran.
Ja, whatever.
So, alles andere ist hier nichts.
Gibt es eigentlich nichts mehr.
So sieht das aus.
recht aufgeräumt. Vielleicht ein bisschen umständlich
da an die Sachen dran zu kommen. Aber mal ganz im Ernst.
Wie oft? Wie oft macht man das
auch schon?
Wie viel RAM-Slot gibt's?
Zwei. Guck da.
Weiß nicht, ob man es richtig erkennt.
Erkennt ihr es da?
Ein RAM-Slot, zweiter RAM-Slot.
Zwei Stück gibt's nur.
Wie kommt man
eigentlich auf 96 GB?
48G
plus 48G, oder?
Ja.
Ach ja, und jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache.
Warum Netzwerkkarte flashen? Was wird geflasht?
Und zwar will ich das Ding hier flashen.
Das ist eine bisschen ältere 10-Gig-Karte.
Das ist... Wartet mal, ich zoome mal kurz ran.
Erkennt man, was das ist? Ja, ne?
Das ist eine Melanox-Karte.
eine melanox connect x3 wie laut ist denn der lüfter es geht also ich habe das ding
letztens hier schon mal angehabt das rauscht wohnzimmer geeignet wahrscheinlich wenn du
im bios ein bisschen tweaking an der lüfter konfiguration was kann ich aber noch nicht
richtig sagen doch der hat rtl 8127 onboard das nicht das ist eine keine
ahnung acht jahre alte 10 gig karte von melanox das gute an melanox ist
melanox gehört übrigens zu nvidia die wurden irgendwann mal gekauft so weit ich
das im hinterkopf habe ja das gute ist die haben ganz guten linux support
und halt auch schon ziemlich alt und das würde ich sagen funzt in der Richtung.
So, warum will ich die Netzwerkkarte flashen?
Hat zwei Gründe.
Erstens will ich PXE-Boot machen können und standardmäßig ist kein PXE-Boot eingeschaltet.
Um das einschalten zu können, habe ich gelesen, ja,
ähm,
Max, die drei sind nicht mehr im Kernel.
Das war, was?
Wie nicht mehr im Kernel?
Die schmeißen doch aus dem Kernel so gut wie nie was raus.
Das glaube ich dir nicht, dass die
in dem Kernel sind.
Warum sollten die
das rausschmeißen?
Wirklich?
Das wäre natürlich doof.
Das wäre natürlich echt
ein Mega-Paints-Champ.
Das muss ich gleich mal nachgucken.
Melanox CX3
Kernel 6.5
Das schauen wir uns gleich mal an.
Also, doch ist es leider...
Was? Ernsthaft?
Es gibt... Nee, oder?
Die wollen mir doch nicht erzählen, dass sie keinen
Kernel-Support mehr für meine Netzwerkkarte haben.
Da muss ich mir eine neue gebrauchte kaufen.
10 GB SFP Plus Karte.
Also, das erste ist, warum ich die wahrscheinlich
flashen muss, ist um PXE zu aktivieren.
das ist standardmäßig nicht aktiviert.
Das kann man wohl aktivieren
mit irgendeinem
Nvidia-Tool? Fragt mich nicht.
Das nächste ist,
man kann SRIOV
einschalten
über eine Custom
Firmware
Config-Datei. Dazu muss man aber
eine Firmware neu flashen.
Chat, wer von euch weiß, was
SRIOV ist?
Ohne zu googeln.
Dann werde ich das mal erklären.
Und zwar, wenn du was virtualisierst, zum Beispiel unter Linux mit KVM.
Weißt du, Nazana weiß es.
Mehrere virtuelle Netzwerke haben.
Ja, genau.
Das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Also wenn du was virtualisierst unter Linux, dann hast du ja das Problem, wie kriegst du Netzwerkkonnektivität in deine VM.
Normalerweise nimmst du dann einen WIT.io Netzwerkadapter, der dann an irgendeiner Bridge auf deinem Hostsystem hängt.
Das heißt, sehr vieles von deinem Netzwerktraffic ist tatsächlich in Software, nicht in Hardware.
das ist für so high performance sachen und 10 gig plus netzwerk bei 10 gig
geht also mit aktueller rechner gehen das geht das auch in cpu in software
aber eine ordentliche ordentlich wunsch netzwerk kann hast ein ordentlich viel
traffic darüber haust dann verursacht das ordentlich cpu last und srv sagt
sorgt dafür dass du aus einer netzwerkkarte mehrere virtuelle
Netzwerkkarten machen kannst, die du dann per PCI-Passthrough in deine VM durchreichst.
Das heißt, du hast dann eine physische Netzwerkkarte, die kann aber in die VM
durchgereicht werden wie ein PCI-Gerät. Das heißt, du kannst in den VMs die volle
Hardware-Offloading und Implementierung von der Netzwerkkarte benutzen und es ist damit
deutlich weniger CPU-intensiv und unterm Strich je nach Hardware auch schneller.
das ist das gleiche wie saio vgpu so und damit das funktioniert muss man wohl eine neue firm
wert drauf flächen da bin ich mal gespannt wie das funktioniert das problem aus das erste was
wir machen müssen ist wir müssen da irgendwas drauf installieren entweder installieren der
Proxmox drauf oder
einen Debian.
Irgendwas in der Richtung.
Zum Netzwerk-Karte
flashen.
Und danach kommt eh Proxmox drauf.
Wir können aber heute
nicht alles im Stream machen. Also wir können nicht
Netzwerk-Karte flashen, plus Proxmox ausprobieren,
plus
NAS-Storage und dann noch irgendwelche
Energie-Performance und sonst was
Test machen. Das machen wir so über die nächsten
1, 2, 3 Streams.
Ich kann mich auch nicht zwölf Stunden jetzt hier am Stück...
Ich weiß, es gibt manche Streamer, die können das, aber ich kann mich keine zwölf Stunden hier hinsetzen und schwätzen.
Das tut mir den Hals weh.
Ja.
Und außerdem, irgendwann schaltet dann mein Kopf auch ab.
Und außerdem kann ich dann Werbung machen zum Followen für die nächsten Streams.
Weil ich hab's immer gerne, wenn's grüne Pfeile gibt, die nach oben zeigen.
Hier, Stonks.
So.
Dann bauen wir das Ding mal wieder zusammen.
Ich schalte mal kurz um.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Ist das wirklich so?
Melanox hier.
Check to see if driver support...
Ja, nee, oder die haben nicht wirklich
die Grafikkartentreiber aus dem Kernel entfernt, oder?
Das ist jetzt nicht den hier in Ernst.
Aber die haben die bei Proxmox bestimmt zusätzlich einkompiliert, oder?
Doch, bestimmt.
Egal, wir probieren das jetzt aus.
Und Chat, wenn es nicht geht, ist auch nicht schlimm.
Dann haben wir wenigstens was gelernt.
Dann können wir kompilieren.
Garantiert nicht für Proxmox.
Schauen wir mal.
So, Moment mal, Chat.
Ich muss den Kram jetzt erst einmal wieder...
Ich muss den Kram jetzt erst einmal wieder zusammenbauen.
Wo habe ich das Case hier?
Also zusammenbauen ist halt auch simpel, ne?
Moment, wartet mal kurz.
Ich hab meine Vorschau-Bild nicht an.
Also im Prinzip...
Im Prinzip musst du dieses Ding einfach nur hier unten reinstecken.
Das muss ich jetzt aber mal hier kurz Off-Kamera machen, weil der Tisch einfach zu klein ist.
Ups, jetzt hab ich's falschrum reingemacht.
Auch sehr schlau.
Ihr guckt.
So, kannst das hier ohne einfach...
Einfach reinstecken.
Zumachen.
Und dann gibt es hier unten noch zwei Schrauben.
Also wenn man es dann wirklich längerfristig mit rein will,
sollte man die Schrauben auch wieder reinmachen.
Ich werde das vielleicht ja heute noch ein paar Mal auf- und zumachen.
Deswegen lassen wir das mal.
Dann stöpsel ich mal an.
Also, wir stöpseln an.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wir stöpseln die...
den KVM
Netzwerk
KVM Geschichte an.
Dann
stöpseln wir
die Netzwerkkarte
an.
Und dann stöpseln
wir
die
Melanox-Karte an.
Hier, SFP+.
Wenn ich es irgendwie auf die Reihe kriege
So
Und dann stöpseln wir zum Schluss den Strom an
Und dann wollen wir mal
Was ist das für ein Nass
Das ist ein Minisforum N5R
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem normalen N5
Oder dem N5 Pro
Ist kein Ugreen
Das Ugreen steht daneben
So, 1 und 2, 1, 6, 8
Achso, ja, haha, oh, Moment
Moment
Ich zeige euch nochmal was Nices
Haben wir das letzte Mal ja im Stream schon benutzt
Aber ich habe es euch noch nicht gezeigt
Meine KVM
Hier
Ich habe jetzt irgendwie keinen Platz
Gucken, ohne dass ich es runterschmeiße
Oh, KVM
Kannst hier vorne drauf drücken
Moment, bisschen sauber machen
So, siehst du die
sieht man die IP.
Ja, ja.
IP.
Und auch was
angeschlossen ist. Anscheinend ist
hier, erkennt er noch
nichts, aber es ist ja auch noch nicht an. Also
insofern, ja.
Und da können wir jetzt gleich netzwerktechnisch
drauf und
gucken wir mal. Ich schalte mal
ein.
Schalte um.
1 für 4 war das die IP.
Jaja.
Was ist das da eigentlich für eine nervige Leistung?
Geh mal fort.
Der PXE bootet schon.
Sehr gut.
Über was PXE bootet der denn jetzt?
Über was hat er jetzt PXE bootet?
Über meine Melanox-Karte?
Oder über...
Ne, die Melanox-Karte ist nicht mal gesynkt am Switch.
So, PXE-Boot ist am Start, Leute
Ist das nicht
Ja, der hat über AR45 geboot
Ist das nicht, sag doch mal
Der schönste PXE-Boot-Screen ever
Ich find schon
So, was installieren wir jetzt da drauf
Debian?
Debian, oder?
Äh, Chat?
Irgendwie hat es gerade meine Tastatur gefressen.
Äh, hallo, Tastaturstelz?
Ja, jetzt geht's.
Wir installieren erstmal Debian.
Proxmox können wir, oder wir können auch Proxmox draufhauen.
komm wir hauen Proxmox drauf oder
können wir gleich mal gucken
ähm
äh
install
install ist mein Custom Debian
wollen wir mal gucken
wie schnell mein Custom Debian
sich installieren lässt
mein Cloud, mein gepatchtes Cloud Image
also nicht gepatchtes Cloud
gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal wie schnell
auf echter Hardware, wobei haben wir doch
letztens sogar schon auf echter Hardware ausprobiert, probieren wir das mal aus
also hier, install
Jetzt kackt erstmal richtig der Encoder ab
Waiting for DHCP
DHCP
Okay, was für IPs haben wir hier
Ja, Moment, ist das jetzt meine
Melanox-Karte
Oh, das ist die Melanox-Karte, glaube ich
ETH-Tool
Ich glaube, das ist die Melanox-Karte
EMP1S0
Jetzt können wir noch
anhand der MAC-Adresse erkennen.
Wartet mal.
Melanox MAC
What?
Hallo?
Okay, gibt's nicht.
Äh.
Oh, fuck.
Hier.
E4. Ja.
E4.
Das ist die Melanox-Karte. Er hat es quasi
gerade über SF4 Plus gebootet.
Ne, nicht gebootet.
Die hat CP geholt
fürs Installen. Aber ist auch egal.
Setup.
Wir installieren
Stable
auf
Chat.
Ah.
Das Menü ist einfach zu klein.
Wir installieren es auf dieser Karte, das ist die interne 58 oder 64 Gig Karte.
Yes.
Debian Hostname, ja ist okay, das ist eh nur temporär.
Was macht eigentlich eine KVM?
KVM nimmt dein Display Output und dein Tastatur In- und Output
und packt das quasi in ein Netzwerk.
ein wie soll man sagen in den netzwerk traffic ein und dann brauchst du eine kleine anwendung
und das ist wie wenn du vorm computer vorm rechner sitzt nur dass es über das netzwerk
geht also ich komme ich bin jetzt hier drauf über das netzwerk auf meiner kvm und kann darüber
mainz server steuern weil die kvm hat ein hdmi eingang und einen usb stecker quasi so ein
Netzwerk-Tastatur
und Netzwerk-Display.
IP-Leak, fuck.
Chat, gucke mal.
Ist kaputt.
Ist funzt nicht.
Mein Installer ist broken.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ist vielleicht mein Raspberry Pi irgendwie im Arsch?
Nö.
ja schon wieder schon in vms hat es bisher immer funktioniert
weiß nicht was er hat
wisst ihr was sein könnte dass die dass die interne ssd einfach nur abfakt langsam ist
ja es ist es hat funktioniert die ssd ist einfach nur lahm install complete
den now rebooting.
Dann reboot
mal.
Reboot.
Worauf läuft eigentlich dein PXE
auf Raspberry Pi 3?
Oder?
Äh, Chat,
wie kriegt man raus, auf welchem Raspberry Pi
man läuft?
Check which
Pi I am using.
Gibt's da irgendwas?
Okay.
Hier.
Raspberry Pi 4.
Warum genau?
Echo der nochmal hinten dran, dass er New Line kriegt oder was?
Raspberry Pi 4 ist das.
Aber Hardware-mäßig brauchst du für ein PXE so gut wie nix.
Gigabit-Netzwerk wäre ganz gut, dass die Images nicht ewig brauchen.
So, da sind wir.
2-1-2-1
Ups, fix SSH
Max stimmt übrigens auch nicht, das muss Debian sein
Fix SSH
Yes
Oh shit, Leute
Ich hab hier gar nicht den SSH-Key
Den richtigen
Wir müssen nochmal kurz installieren
Jetzt im richtigen SSH-Key
Sekunde.
Ähm.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Der hier.
Woblos.
Ja.
Das ist übrigens kein Leak.
Die Adresse steht als Business-Kontakt da.
Falls wieder jemand rein will.
Das müssen wir nochmal neu installieren, weil ich keinen SSH-Key drauf habe.
Sehr schlau, Max.
Exzellent.
High IQ.
also falsche knopf
die lex critical information ja
denn ins bios wir müssen mal kurz auf meinen hier wir müssen mal hier war
www.html.com fix muss hier mein ssh key rein konflikt genau okay so das sollte jetzt hoffentlich
funktioniert, nachdem ich wieder installiere.
Äh.
Boot Options.
Okay.
Der bootet über
die eingebaute Netzwerkkarte.
Über Kupfer.
Und jetzt?
Hallo?
Hä?
Jetzt bootet er nicht über die...
Was ist das für ein komisches Bios?
Hast du jetzt mitbekommen, dass Denik
jetzt Klarnamen und Anschrift zu allen DE-Domains
in Hues stellt? Ach ja.
Das wollen sie doch die ganze Zeit
nicht.
Ist das so?
Denik
Wie passt das mit DSGVO und so zusammen?
Wo hast du denn das her?
Hast du da einen Newspost dazu?
Oh man, ich bin zu lahm, Leute.
Ich bin zu lahm.
Restart, restart, restart, restart.
Jetzt auf, restart.
Will nicht.
Restart.
So, ähm
Boot Options
Ja, wie kann ich den jetzt hier booten lassen davon?
Enter drücken?
Das BIOS ist schon ein bisschen für den Arsch, oder?
Okay, Boot Options, Boot
Dann stelle ich, ey, wisst ihr was?
Dann stelle ich es halt hier um
Ich sag hier
Network Boot als erstes.
Als nächstes
die Debian Hard Disk.
CD brauchen wir nicht.
Als nächstes USB.
Ne, ganz ehrlich, die Kombination ist so rum.
Network USB
Debian.
Und das hier kann
ehrlich gesagt, ist mir vollkommen egal. Das kann das Elbe
bleiben. Ah, Hard Disk.
Das letzte ist CD.
Äh.
was genau ist jetzt passiert?
Jetzt bootet er auch, okay.
Jetzt installieren wir nochmal Debian.
In der Hoffnung.
Wisst ihr was?
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir sind ja hier nicht dabei,
mein PXE-Kram zu debuggen.
Doch, doch, einmal testen wir es noch.
Es geht ja schnell.
Install.
Wir installieren jetzt Debian Testing. Da haben wir auch neueste Kram am Start. Diskette. Das
geht mittlerweile über USB Boot. Floppy to USB. Habe ich das denn schön gebaut? Diesen Installer
hier da freue ich mich richtig hier wie gut das funst
ok jetzt weiß ich auch warum das so lange hängt das schreibt auf den internen
cache von der ssd und bis die ssd den ganzen kram weggeschrieben hat dauert
einfach gefühlt zwei minuten also die ssd ist schrott die daten
standardmäßig drin ist die 64 version leute ich glaube wir machen das ding
gleich noch einmal auf und schrei schrauben die 970 evo rein
weil die ssd ist wirklich schrott die kackt mir wahrscheinlich nach einem
halben jahr einfach nur lock schreiben ab
ok
Update für die HUS-Abfrage.
Das ändert sich jetzt.
Seit dem Set gelten noch neue Gesetze. Hintergrund, Umsetzung
der NIST 2. Richtig. Was ändert sich?
Grundsätzlich gilt unheimlich...
Natürlich oder richtig...
Okay.
Juristischer Portion...
Ach so, okay.
Ah, gut.
Das sackt halt richtig den.
Guck jetzt.
Guck mal, wie lange der braucht, bis die SSD das wirklich gesynct hat.
So.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, ob mein SSH-Login funktioniert.
Ach, ich habe jetzt ja PXE-Boot-First eingestellt.
Jetzt bootet er immer PXE.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so clever.
Dann muss ich jetzt immer warten, bis PXE-Boot
timed outet.
Guck, der Timed-Out jetzt nach 5 Sekunden bootet lokal.
Äh, okay.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so schlau gewesen,
weil ich da eingestellt habe.
Aber gucken wir mal, ob der Login jetzt funktioniert.
Melanox? Guck mal, im Kernel ist es noch drin.
Okay.
Was?
Oh, was habe ich denn da wieder mit meinen Keys gemacht?
Contents do not match public key?
Och, Max.
Was hast du denn da mit deinen SSH-Keys schon wieder
rumgesaut, Alter?
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Scheiß drauf.
Wir installieren jetzt Debian.
Normal.
Nee, wir installieren Debian nicht normal.
Ich will, dass mein eigener Installer funzt hier.
Cat.
Papp.
Der wird doch wenigstens funktionieren, oder?
Wie in...
Max at Poggers.
Wie in 2020, Alter.
Er ist Arki.
So, beste.
Und das schmeißen wir wieder raus.
Nochmal.
Das muss jetzt.
Das muss jetzt funktionieren, Leute.
Aber wenigstens haben wir jetzt nicht das Problem,
dass er nicht pxe bootet. Außerdem geht's ja schnell.
Jetzt geht er
zackig.
Ja, achso, hab ich eigentlich schon
erzählt, warum ich die Netzwerkkarte flashen will
jetzt? Ich glaub schon, ne? Also, kurz
gesagt, ich will meine Netzwerkkarte flashen. Erstens,
dass sie pxe booten kann. Also, nicht
die Netzwerkkarte, die hier gerade pxe bootet,
sondern die, äh, andere.
die Kupfernetzwerkkarte, äh die Glasfasernetzwerkkarte oder die SFP-Plus-Netzwerkkarte, die soll PXE booten können und dann will ich SAIOV einschalten.
Genau, so, install.
Wenn es jetzt nicht geht, installiere ich danach nochmal Debian, okay.
Mir gefällt aber mein eigener Installer
Mit dem richtig nice-u
Das einzige, was ich nicht so nice-u finde
Ist die interne SSD
Weil die ist wirklich lahm
Guck, im Cache ist das alles schnell
Aber du bist auch wirklich gesynct und geflasht
Auf die
Stimmt, Chat
Wir könnten auch ein Arch Linux installieren
Eine Cache-iOS könnten wir installieren
Da habe ich wenigstens gleich was ordentliches dabei.
Ne, machen wir nicht.
McFly, dankeschön.
Für den Sub.
Sorry, falls ich irgendjemanden übersehen habe.
War gerade so beschäftigt.
Mit Nassstelz.
Also die nächsten Streams über werden wir das machen.
Also wir werden dann erst mal hier angucken, wie ist die Performance der Netzwerkkarten, wie ist der Stromverbrauch.
wie schnell ist der Netzwerkstall,
CPU-Performance und sowas.
Gucken wir uns an, sowohl vom
Minisforum
N5R
und von den
Ugreen Nassus 4800
Plus und 4800 Pro.
Schauen wir uns an. Wir benutzen
die gleichen SSDs.
Gleiche SSDs, die werden dann einfach
umgebaut.
Wie viel RAM hat das Minisforum,
so viel wieder reinsteckst.
Ich hab's ohne RAM gekauft und hab
32 GB eingebaut, weil ich die noch hatte.
Hätte ich das mal
vor einem halben oder einem Jahr gewusst, ey,
dann hätte ich mir noch ein bisschen DDR5 RAM gekauft.
Aber nachher bist...
Das ist wie, hätte ich mir 1990 Apple-Aktien gekauft, ja.
Nachher bist du immer schlauer.
Stonks.
Okay, das PXE-Zeug muss ich
dann gleich wieder ausschalten. Kann man das abbrechen,
eigentlich? Aha.
Man kann abbrechen.
Ja, das ist doch gut zu wissen.
Also nachrüsten kann ich bei den Minisformen
jetzt gerade nichts mehr, weil beide RAM-Slots
sind belegt.
Also ich habe zweimal 16 Gig drin.
Ganz ehrlich.
Chat, wie seht ihr das? 32 Gig
für ein paar VMs
und ein paar Netzwerkshares
und vielleicht ein paar Container.
Das reicht dicke.
Oder wie seht ihr das?
Das reicht, das reicht.
Dicke.
Ah, wir sind eingeloggt.
Kein ECC.
Ja, juckt ja auch nicht.
Dass ich kein ECC hab und ZFS verwende,
das würde höchstens Leute im Freenas-Forum triggern.
Aber hier nix.
Aber hier kein.
Lokaler, selbst für lokale KI reicht das
Ich würde bei lokaler KI
Würde ich ja irgendein simpleres Model nehmen
Oder aber halt irgendwas, was halt auch gut auf die SSD passt
Bisschen knauserig
Ja, lass mal 600 Euro für den RAM ausgeben
Ich hab jetzt schon
2000 Euro für Nasses fast ausgegeben
Weil ich sinnlos
Peepo Burn Money nass bestellt hab.
Aber ich schick wieder was zurück.
Und eins, wenn ihr brav seid,
Chat,
wenn ihr brav seid und high IQ seid,
dann
giveaway ich vielleicht eins von den Nasses.
Also nicht das, was ich
behalten werde. Das wär ja irgendwie blödsinnig.
Das 4800 plus
giveaway ich dann.
Oder aber ich gib's
oder aber ich frage erst mal auf discord im mod gecheckt ob einer was braucht
mod ist wenn er sonst schon nicht bezahlt vielleicht braucht ja einer
trinken zu lassen
du schickst auch zwei nass wieder zurück ich kann wahrscheinlich dass ukraine
4800 plus nicht mehr zurück schicken weil die 14 tage schon um sind also dem
ihr anstellt dass immer leute also erstmal ab update erstmal die wichtigen
Sachen machen.
Upt, Upgrade.
So, jetzt die wichtigen Sachen gleich
erstmal installieren.
Lass mal kurz checken,
wie es mit dem RAM aussieht.
Oder an die Katzenhilfe. Naja, gut.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, die Katzenhilfe braucht
kein Nass, die Katzenhilfe braucht Geld und Futter
und sowas. Okay, wir haben...
Warte mal. Upt, Install, Nv, Top.
Wie viel RAM braucht meine Grafikkarte aktuell?
Also ich habe hier 29 GB.
Bestimmt hat die Grafikkarte noch ein bisschen was.
No GPU to Monitor.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ja.
Warum?
Warum nicht?
Äh.
Was ist denn da drin?
was ist nun mal so kurz gucken was ist da drin radion 7000 lsp c-repp minus i
definition
chat wie finde ich habe danach hat die radion eben geklebt und da hat er nichts gefunden
eine audio controller chat wo finde ich denn meine grafikkarte hier drin
avga aber ich weiß woran das liegt ati geil kann das sein dass das blacklisted ist kann das sein
dass das blacklisted ist bei proxmox weil leute wollen ja in der regel die grafikkarte bei proxmox
in die VMs durchreichen, oder?
Blacklist-Conf.
Nee, PC-Speaker und Floppy.
Okay, okay.
Okay, ist nicht.
Ähm.
Du blacklistest, um es durchreichen zu können.
Jetzt meine ich ja.
Deswegen sehe ich es vielleicht auf dem
NV-Top.
Stimmt ich habe demian installiert auch kein proxmox das recht amd gpu
Kann die igp im bios deaktiviert sein
gucke also ich war wirklich deaktiviert sein kann es ja nicht ich habe hier ein output von der gpu
mod info amd gpu
sehe ich da jetzt irgendwas?
OKS.
Mod Probe
AMD GPU.
Hä?
Ey, das ist bestimmt einfach zu alt.
NV Top Minus Minus Version.
NV Top, was ist denn da die aktuelle Version?
Ja.
Oha, 3.2 ist von
naja so alt ist es nicht wir fragen jetzt mal die ki die weiß da bestimmt was da bestimmt bescheide
einfach nur mit einem dgp den modernen amd gp okay
Radion Top
Okay
Ich will eigentlich nur gucken, wie viel RAM meine GPU hat
Unknown, unknown, unknown
Okay, das ist auch nicht so geil
Okay
So ein Funst ist schon mal nicht
ähm
tja
äh
brauche ich da eine neuere Version von oder
fehlt der aktuellste
Treiber ist ein Linux
5.14 und neuer erforderlich
guck mal hier das ist ja
longer habe ich das
Suchen wir mal hier
MV Top
Wir gehen gleich nochmal ins Bios und gucken nochmal
700, was war das?
780 M, oder?
780 M
Okay
DevDRI.
What?
Gibt es gar nicht?
Okay.
Da ist er dreimal nicht richtig geladen.
Oder was?
Oder wie?
Oder wo?
Was ist da los?
Das ist Blödsinn.
Was ist denn?
Was zum Teufel?
Ich copy-paste einfach nur sinnlos.
Okay.
Mod Pro. Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich...
Kann ich den unloaden?
Minus R, AMD-GPU.
Okay, ist jetzt mein Display aus?
Nee.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
es ist dann wenigstens aus.
Mod Info, AMD-GPU.
Sehe ich da irgendwie,
ob der jetzt...
Das macht man so selten.
modprobe amd gpu.
Tür geladen.
Aha.
Guck mal.
Jetzt.
Jetzt meckert er hier.
Aha. Guck mal da.
Also irgendwelche Sachen haben Funs nicht.
Okay.
Seriously, Leute, kein Plan
Fatal Error during GPU-Init
Geil
Das ist natürlich ganz toll
Dort fehlt die Firmware
Muss ich noch hier irgendwie
AMD oder irgendwas nachinstallieren?
Irgendein Firmware-Package oder so?
Bla, bla, bla
Install missing IMD.
Äh.
Hä?
Das kann ich mir nicht wirklich vorstellen.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn,
was die AI hier mir...
Search.
Firmware.
Ah, ach, muss ich Dings installieren?
Muss ich, muss ich
unfree Repos anmachen oder so?
Kann das sein?
Ich muss bestimmt
unfree Repos machen, weil das irgendein Binary Shit
ist von Nvidia, äh, von, von...
Wir haben wo er amd
Nee, nee, nee, meine berufsbereiche ist ich bin
Senior linux engineer aber bald bin ich senior site reliability engineer warum fragt mich nicht weil es cooler klingt
debian linux firmware amd gpu
der gut schätzt sie heißt non free firmware ok debian enable non free firmware da musste
man noch irgendeinen Mist eintragen.
Ich weiß aber beim besten Willen nicht mehr, wie das geht.
Hier, genau. Contrib non-free
muss man machen.
Excellent.
Oh, das ist das neue Format.
Fuck.
Keine Ahnung, wie das neue Format funktioniert.
Okay.
Enable non-free
Firmware.
Kein Schimmer.
Ach, hier einfach hinten dran, oder was?
Okay, easy.
Schauen wir mal, ob uns die...
Schauen wir mal, ob uns die AI nicht anlügt.
Kommt ja auch öfters vor.
Update.
Okay, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Warum interessiere ich mich eigentlich für meine Grafikkarte, Chat?
Das ist komplett unrelevant eigentlich für heute.
Achso, weil ich gucken wollte, wie viel RAM die Grafikkarte verbraucht.
Was jetzt?
Wie der irgendeinen super lahmen Mirror erwischt, hä?
Okay, Brunst.
Up, Search.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Wir haben die install und findet er das nicht
Okay.
Aber das gibt es doch bei
Batrixi.
Habe ich da auch non-free Firmware reingemacht?
Ach, non-free.
Ich muss non...
Free.
Pirmware auch noch reinmachen, ha?
MonkaS, Alter.
Update.
So, jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Jetzt.
Okay.
WTF.
Da muss er erstmal drauf kommen.
Okay, jetzt.
NV, top.
Ah, Moment, ich muss nochmal laden.
Mod probe minus R AMD GPU
Mod probe
So, wurde
anloadet jetzt, okay.
Mod probe AMD
Dmesk minus T
Gucken wir mal. 13.07, also jetzt
Ja gut,
meine Uhrzeit stimmt nicht.
Ah, das habe ich in meinem Install Image nicht drin.
Egal.
Mod probe
AMD GPU
Ah, es hat funktioniert.
NV top.
Es geht.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
First try.
Easy.
Get rekt.
Easy as fuck.
Also.
Wie viel RAM hat denn jetzt die GPU, Chat?
Ich bin blind.
Wo steht es denn da?
2 GB.
Ganz ehrlich, für ein reines Virtualisierungssystem könnte ich der GPU durchaus noch ein paar Gig wegnehmen, oder?
Aber lassen wir es erstmal.
Halten wir uns mal gar nicht mit so einem kleinen Kram aus.
Viel interessanter Chat.
Jetzt wird die Netzwerkkarte geflasht.
Also, ifconfig.
Fragt mich bitte nicht, warum ifconfig.
Ich bin ifconfig-Enjoyer.
eth 0 eth tool eth 0 so direct attached copper das ist auf jeden fall die melanox karte wir
können auch sagen hier fiber er hat gesünd mit 10 gig guck mal was er für ein treiber benutzt
er benutzt die minus ist das glaube ich gern minus er benutzt mlx 4n version 4.0
ich suche keine ex für nix für externe gpu
was ist eine intel intel b 50 wird ein kampfflugzeug 8 die dinger
aber brauchen
Ach, da kann man für AI-Stells oder was?
Ja, eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache.
Gibt es hier auch Low-Profile mit ordentlich RAM?
Dass die vielleicht ins PCI Express reinpasst?
Ne, oder? Die ist eindeutig zu fett für meinen internen PCI Express Slot.
ist eindeutig zu dick
16 gig ist gar nicht mal so übel
und jetzt auch gar nicht mal so krassteuer oder was fällt euch empfohlen
Die B50 ist Low Profile und kann...
Und wie viel RAM hat die?
Memory? 16!
Ey, für lokalen AI-Stells ist das glaube ich gar nicht mal so übel, oder?
Also ich habe da wirklich Anwendungszweck für.
Aber die Idee finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Das Book mag ich mir mal.
So, also.
Weiter im Text.
Ich will meine Netzwerkkarte flashen.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken.
Davon habe ich jetzt nämlich wirklich keine Ahnung.
Ich labere jetzt nicht nur.
Manchmal verarsche ich euch ja ein bisschen und sage, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber in Wirklichkeit habe ich mir das vorher schon mal angeguckt.
Aber heute habe ich tatsächlich keine Ahnung.
Wie kriege ich denn raus?
Also ich will PXE-Boot einschalten.
Wie schalte ich?
Okay.
Melanox
Connect
X
By the way, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat
Ihr habt doch gesagt, angeblich ist der Support aus dem Kernel rausgeflogen
Aber wie kann das sein?
Ich habe einen 612er Kernel
Und der Melanox Support ist immer noch drinnen
Vielleicht so ein Debian Ding?
Hat Debian das noch einkompiliert?
Debian Remove
CX3 Support
Melanox
Wie, ich lüge euch? Ich sorge nur für besseren Content.
Ey, das ist doch Blödsinn.
Sehr gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich nur keine Updates mehr
Ja, weil ganz ehrlich, es wäre mir doch auch neu, dass die das
Linux remove
Die entfernen doch nie was
Ja, jetzt ver- Patrick, nicht alles verraten
Sonst wirke ich doch gar nicht mal so high IQ
Was ist das jetzt?
Hä?
Chat, irgendjemand hatte vorhin einen Link dazu.
Okay, wie funzt das hier?
Ich hab den echt richtig geplant.
Okay, absearch.
Wir machen es mal ganz doof.
Melanox.
Was findet er denn, wenn ich Melanox suche?
mst flint melanox firma burning application dkms nvidia firma burning tool was ist das
jetzt das auf github open source version of mft melanox firmware tools also ich
will erst mal nur pxe einschalten melanox cx3 enable pxe was ist das hier
okay da der led was runter der led in
Okay, was ist MFT und was ist MST?
MST?
Open Source Version MFT.
Chat, jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Warum gibt es vom Hersteller eine Open Source Version eines anderen Tools von Ihnen, das nicht Open Source...
Hä?
Der Hersteller hat zwei Tools.
Sie machen das gleiche.
Eins ist Open Source, eins ist Closed Source.
Aber beides ist vom Hersteller.
vielleicht dürfen sie es eigentlich mehr frei ok also mst mst sollte sollte
anscheinend auch also ab install melanox firma okay brauche ich denn brauche ich
denn diese dkms geschichten
das brauche ich brauche ich weil guck mal hier da macht hier an jeder setzt
setzt das direkt.
Dev MST.
Sowas habe ich nicht. Okay, wir installieren
mal beides. Wir installieren die DKMS.
Also die Kernel-Modul-Stells und
das...
Okay, erstmal 30 Milliarden Sachen installieren.
Sehr gut.
Das weiß ich nicht, aber es sind
Dynamic Kernel Modules oder irgendwie
sowas. DKMS Linux.
Dynamic Kernel Modules Support, genau.
Okay.
MST
So und wie geht das jetzt angeblich?
MLX-Config, gibt es sowas wie
MXT-Config?
Minus D
Ja was weiß ich denn
Was muss denn da hin?
Hab ich denn, ah Moment, hab ich jetzt
DEVM?
Hab ich nicht
Weder MST noch sonst was
Hat das vielleicht nicht funktioniert?
Mod, Mod, Probe.
Probe, äh.
MST?
Ne, was? LS-Mod?
Ja, minus I, MST.
Ne, äh, äh, oh, fuck.
Wie lässt denn man Kernelmodule?
Äh, Lib?
Äh, wo ist der Kram?
Lib, ähm.
Ja, nur geladene Kernelmodule.
Ich will ja auch nicht geladene Kernelmodule.
Oder besser gesagt,
How to list
DKMS Modules.
List of Packages.
DKMS Status.
Ah, ja, ja.
Ja, alles weiß ich auch nicht aus dem Kopf.
MS Flint.
Also kann ich jetzt sagen, Modprobe?
MS Flint oder was?
Keine Ahnung, Mann.
Warum weiß ich, wie dieses
Kernel-Modul heißt?
Muss ich dafür rebooten?
Reboot.
Wir rebooten mal.
Das kann auf jeden Fall nichts schaden.
Ah Mist, Mist, Mist.
Ja, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Entering Setup.
Äh.
Äh, Boot.
Moment, ich, ich, ich
stell das mal kurz um.
Save. Oh, was ist denn hier los?
Es backt ein bisschen rum gerade.
Vielleicht soll ich doch mal
Firmware-Update von der KVM machen.
ok ssh ab das kind amd gpu ist es auch im start aber ich bin kein voll husten
So, Grafikkarte wird jetzt auch immer geladen.
Alter.
So.
MST.
Ne, warte.
Was ist das für eine KVM?
Eine GL.
GL Inet Pro Comet oder sowas.
ja das ding eigentlich ziemlich nice bis in kabelsalat aber an sich na ist okay
mod probe ms tf und okay das heißt schon mal nicht so
wie finde ich denn jetzt wie das heißt was ich laden muss gibt es da vielleicht
in das system ctl mst auto laut module ja echt kein planer das macht man so selten
es nord bin bild installiert step by step man kann ich nicht dkm dk ms auto install machen
Error.
Was?
Kernel-Headers fehlen.
Es gibt Header, Alter.
Upt, Install, Linux.
Linux, Headers.
Ach, wie hieß denn der Kram?
Headers.
Linux, irgendwas mit Linux hieß der Kram doch.
Linux Headers, gibt es da nicht so ein Generic Package für?
Immer das Aktuellste installieren?
Ach, Linux Headers AMD 64.
Mich motiviert die Musik voll.
So, jetzt aber.
DKMS Auto install.
Ah, ja.
Schon besser.
Okay.
Ups, oh, jetzt habe ich abgebraucht.
Ich bin so doof.
Oh, lau.
Ich habe Ctrl-C gedrückt.
Okay, wie, wie?
Okay, Build.
Build.
Moment, der bildet immer noch.
Kann das sein?
Guck mal, der bildet immer noch.
Der lässt sich...
Der ist schlau, der lässt sich nicht abbrechen.
Der ist high IQ.
Guck mal.
Der lässt sich nicht abbrechen.
Guck, der läuft immer noch.
Wobei der mir verdächtig lange braucht, ehrlich gesagt.
äh, chat, chat, chat,
ich glaube, ich hab's kaputt gemacht,
ich glaube, ich hab's irgendwie mit meinem Abbrechen, hab ich's irgendwie,
äh, kann man das,
kann man das nochmal neu bilden,
Bild,
ach, shit, man,
Damit kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Was gibt es denn da?
Install? Remove?
Remove?
Wie ist dieses Ding?
Ne.
Was?
Uninstall?
Du musst unbedingt ein Module angeben.
Okay, DKMS-Status.
Also, okay, okay.
Also brauche ich das da.
So.
Ah, ja.
Okay, okay.
Auto-Install.
Okay, jetzt.
Succeeded.
Sehr schön.
Mod-Probe.
Ja, wie lade ich das denn jetzt?
Ich bin da echt zu doof für.
Also so ist schon mal nett.
MS Flick...
Woher weißt du, dass das so heißt?
Wie kriegst du das...
Wie hast du das gefunden?
Minus L?
oder irgendwie ist. LS Mod?
Aber da steht's.
Warum steht das gar nicht drin, ne?
Okay, das ist von uns.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung, warum.
Okay.
Linux, find all available
kernel modules.
Wie macht man das?
User-Lib-Check. Na gut.
Currently loaded.
Okay, dann war ich doch prinzipiell
eh mal gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich sag, wir gucken da rein.
Warte mal.
Und da...
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Da hätte man das rausgekriegt
MST Flint
Heißt das
So und jetzt habe ich das geladen
Habe ich jetzt ein Def MST
Habe ich auch nicht
Ja und was hat das jetzt gebracht
Als ich das geladen habe
Was war da jetzt der Sinn von
Nichts
Nice
und die weiß das schon mal gut dass an die weiß gefördert hat google
würdest du eigentlich dass ukraine os auf dem nass lassen das tat mir überhaupt nicht zugesagt
oder ein anderes ich würde was ja ja ich würde auf jeden fall was neu ist gar nicht so sehr
wegen China-Spionage, sondern weil ich das
glaube, das taugt nix.
So.
Ich hab absolut...
Dazu gibt es ja auch keinerlei gescheite
Tutorials.
Also, was soll ich machen? Conf... Okay.
LS-PCI
Minus E-Melanox.
So, da findet... Okay, hier ist die
PCI-ID.
Brauchen wir das hier. MST...
Ne, wie ist das? MST-Config?
Config?
Und jetzt was?
Minus D-Device?
Da muss man bestimmt...
Das habe ich doch irgendwo hier gerade gesehen.
MST-Config-Example.
Ja, guck mal.
Da musst du die PC-ID eingeben.
MS-Config minus, was war das?
Minus D, dann hier das Device und Query.
Haben die da den Support entfernt?
Mh.
Mstflint 4.31.
Was gibt's denn hier sonst noch?
Mstdeviceinfo.
AST Device Info.
So, man, da findet die doch.
Aber warum ist das not supported?
Michael, 50 Billion.
Moin.
Och, fuck, Alter.
Ja, not working.
Aber sag mal,
DevMST gibt es
bei mir nicht.
Ich suche jetzt mal danach.
MST not working.
Wobei das Ding heißt eigentlich
CX3
habe ich überall. Die kürzen das alle ab.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Segmentation fault devices.
so mst start mst ich habe kein kommando was mst heißt
soll ich das hier start so machen vielleicht
vielleicht brauche ich auch das ding von nvidia direkt keine ahnung was haben wir
hier, I'm seeing white issue.
Was? Och, och, hört
mir auf, Leute. Meine
Güte, heute haben sie es aber echt.
Heute wollen sie mich aber echt alle abfacken, oder?
Okay, okay, okay.
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat. Ich hab, ich hab ne Idee.
Ich hab ne Idee.
Was hat denn Bookworm
für eine Version davon.
4.21.
Perfekt.
Leute, wir
können uns einfach das Paket
runterladen von Bookworm.
Was ein Act.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich will den Browser halt nicht killen.
So.
Okay.
Okay, apt remove msc Sternchen.
Ach, ach, ach, ach.
Ja, ja.
Wechselst Sternchen.
Okay.
Befolge uns, Jürich.
Was machen wir gerade?
Wir versuchen, eine Netzwerkkarte zu flashen.
Also, was wieder Patrick schon sagt.
Neue Firmware, wobei ich gar nicht sicher bin, ob wir neue Firmware brauchen.
aber schon dabei sind machen wir das letzte war die letzte firma drauf und zwar ich will
px e boot in hebel und es sei uv in ebel meine netzwerkkarte wie viel brauche ich gerade an
strom von meinem las 17 watt geht eigentlich klar für das dass es voll bestückt ist mit
3 Netzwerkkarten.
3 SSDs.
Wir könnten vielleicht nochmal Power Top.
Warte mal, das machen wir jetzt mal. Install.
Power Top. Einfach nur
Just for Fun, weil ich wissen will, ob es was bringt.
Power. Ne, das machen wir.
Komm, egal. Power Top, minus, minus.
Auto, Tune.
Und wie viel brauchen wir jetzt?
16,9.
Es ist ein bisschen
gefallen 17 16,9 17 watt bisschen bisschen was kann man strom gespart
ok also ich wollte jetzt das dem paket installieren also ab install punkt
slash mst flint error
jetzt habe ich zu neue pakete als dependencies
ok chat
ich habe eine idee
bevor wir bookworm installieren nix os rescued uns jetzt wir installieren das über nixos das
gibt es bestimmt eine alte version über nixos da muss ich da muss ich nur mal kurz gucken
wie man dieses komische Package nochmal für
NixOS installiert hat.
Ähm, muss ich mal
in Templates gucken.
Spring.
Dockerfile.
Ne, äh, ach, fuck.
Base
oder so, Base.
Ansonsten, wenn gar nichts hilft, Leute, wenn gar nichts
installiert, installieren wir Arch Linux.
Ähm,
Ich hab doch hier nix irgendwo.
Hier.
Nix. Enf.
Hier, das da such ich. Nix. Install. No Demon.
Ist not supported.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
also die sind sie schon hart anstrengend heute war damals search mix es gibt es
nicht über die package manager nix
Ne, oder?
Nix Setup.
Ah, guck mal da.
Oder das da.
Pure Functional Package Manager.
Upinstall.
Gut.
Guck mal, heute gehen noch nicht mal die Repos, die ihr auswählt.
Kannst du das nicht auch über einen Docker-Container machen?
Das wird schwierig
mit direktem PC-Geräte-Access
und sowas.
Vielleicht irgendwie
mit einem Privileged-Container
und irgendwelchen... Also vielleicht, vielleicht, ja.
Das wird auf jeden Fall eklig.
Okay, Chat. Also.
Denke.
Jetzt haben wir nix installiert.
So, wie installen wir da jetzt was?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Hier, nix, nix, nf.
Was macht das?
Was macht das hier jetzt?
Gott, warum ist das alles so kompliziert heute?
Ich muss mal in meinem Dockerfile gucken, was ich da eigentlich mache.
Was ist das?
Damit kann man Packages installieren, die es nicht im Standard-Repo gibt.
Ja, das mache ich da.
Also, das hält sich echt in Grenzen,
was ich da mache, oder?
Hm.
Okay, Base.
Wo habe ich das denn?
Dev-Container, Docker-File, Base.
Ne, da mache ich da eigentlich nur ein Install.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wisst ihr was? Draufgeschissen.
Apt, Remove,
nix.
Setup System D.
Nix. Pin.
Scheiß drauf. Wir machen das so, wo ich weiß, dass es funktioniert.
Add User. Max.
Ja, ja, ja. Wunderbar.
Yes.
Upt. Install. Sudo.
Sudo.
User. Mod.
Frag mich nicht, ey.
Bim. ETC.
Group.
Max.
So, Max kommt in die Gruppe für Wheel.
Oder Sudo.
Sudo.
Da gibt es den User Debian drauf.
Aha, excellent.
Dann darf der doch hier doch schon alles machen.
Ne, dann machen wir es doch hier mit.
Was?
RM minus RF slash nix.
Ja, finally, Alter.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal,
ob es das überhaupt mal gibt.
Mixed Packages.
MST?
Hier, guck mal.
Gibt es doch.
Guck mal, das ist 4.3.4.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Jetzt die Frage, wie installiert man mit NixOS alte Versionen?
Das geht da doch
bestimmt easy how to install old version nix auto install alles was
es
Ja, minus F.
Ah, ja.
Was zum...
Okay, das
lügt wieder.
Ah.
Mix, Env, Install,
Old Version. Das kann doch nicht sein, dass
dass das so kompliziert ist. Die erzählen doch
immer, nix ist so geil für
reproduzierbare...
reproduzierbare
Sachen.
Okay.
There is no nix native way of
doing that. Was? Hä?
Aber die erzählen doch alle immer, nix ist so geil für
reproduzierbare Sachen. Da muss man doch alte Versionen
installieren können.
Also, das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Package Name
MST
Wie heißt das Ding?
MST Flint
Okay
Keine Wildcard Suche
Wir haben hier
Okay
4.17 ist okay.
Revision.
Ach, guck mal, da gibt es sogar...
Ach, das ist ja nice.
Das ist ja nice.
Guck mal, da kann man sogar einfach Copy-Pasten.
Ein Reboot.
Anscheinend bin ich nicht der Einzige, der das Problem hat.
Was auch immer wir da gerade überhaupt installieren, ey.
Aber kann ich das jetzt überhaupt benutzen?
Weil da sind ja keine DKMS-Sachen jetzt dabei.
Okay.
Nee, nee, nee, geht.
Which?
MST-Config?
Ja doch, ist richtig.
MST-Config.
Warte mal.
LSPCI.
Grab Melanox.
So, 001.
So, wie war das jetzt?
MST-Config?
Chat, bevor ich es jetzt tippe.
Meint ihr, das geht jetzt?
Der kann jetzt auf die Netzwerkkarte zugreifen oder nicht?
Wollen wir mal abstimmen?
Komm, wir machen mal einen Poll.
Geht das jetzt mit dem
Nix-Package
die Netz...
geht
Netzwerkkarte Listen.
Ja, nein.
Bin mal gespannt.
Bin mal gespannt, was ihr sagt.
Ich tippe, nee, ich sag nicht, worauf ich tippe.
Ist DevMST da?
Nee.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich hab's ja nicht gestartet.
Und ich glaub,
mit nix kann ich auch keine
Kernel-Module da irgendwie
reinhauen, oder?
Uff,
turft sich.
Wisst ihr Leute, wenn alles stregig
reißt, installiere ich halt einfach Bookworm.
Habe ich zwar nicht in meinem PXE-Server
drin, aber das ist einfach nur ein
Pull vom ISO und reinpacken, ja.
Oder fast.
Fast ein Pull und reinpacken.
Ihr habt es euch wieder zur Aufgabe gemacht,
50-50 rauskommen zu lassen, oder?
Was ist das für ein PXE-Server
auf dem Raspberry Pi?
Den habe ich gebastelt.
Auch teilweise hier im Stream.
Nein.
Okay, ich tippe auch drauf,
dass es nicht funktioniert.
Also.
MST-Config
minus D
Query.
Ah, Sudo.
home moment chat bin ich verwirrt das geht ja mit sudo nicht weil ich okay okay okay okay sekunde
Okay, ich führ das jetzt einfach aus
Okay
Also, minus D
Oh, da war es doch, minus D
Ja
Ha, fuck
Moment, das hat jetzt
Das hat jetzt so halb funktioniert
Guck mal
Der erkennt das Device
und jetzt sagt er,
Leute, das liegt jetzt,
ich sage euch, woran das liegt.
Das liegt jetzt daran, dass wir keine Kernel-Module haben.
Gibt es denn hier MST?
Nee, gibt es nicht. Also, up, install,
MST, flint,
DKMS,
das ist jetzt eine wilde Mischung, ne?
Eine wilde Mischung.
Wir installieren jetzt die Kernelmodule
Und
Benutzen das
Das funktioniert nicht
Okay, Chat
Bookworm wird installiert
Es wird Bookworm installiert
es wird bookworm installiert okay bookworm ist aber noch nicht auf
einem pxd server drauf das heißt chat ich muss mal kurz mein
mein installer skript updaten da müssen wir kurz mal high iq machen das
würde schnell hinkriegen also debian installer wo ist der debian
install oh ich habe ja alles aus kommentiert das ist auch nicht so nicht
so schlau
das ist auch nicht so schlau debian debian debian installa debian installer den muss
ich umbenennen debian installer stable und stable und alt stable
Debian Installer
Stable, All Stable
All Stable
So, also Debian Dist
Wie heißt hier das
Also, das gibt es hier, gibt es hier was wie All Stable
Fuck
Oh, ach, All Stable streikt man zusammen
All Stable, okay
Easy
Easy, easy.
Debian.
Old stable.
Der Rest ist dynamisch.
So, Moment. Das geht jetzt aber nicht nach Debian, sondern nach Debian old stable.
Old stable. Das könnte ich vielleicht auch mal in eine Variable schreiben.
Das wäre ganz sinnvoll.
Old stable.
So, wenn ich das alles richtig gemacht habe, sollte das jetzt eigentlich schon funktionieren.
Update SH.
Okay.
Hat funktioniert.
So einfach kann es sein.
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Boot Entry.
Debian Installer.
Debian.
Machen wir das hier unten hin.
Old Debian Installer, Old, Stable.
Und dann müssen wir das hier kopieren.
Debian Installer.
Debian Installer, Old, Stable.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig genannt?
Old?
Ah, das hier habe ich nur Old genannt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
muss schon so heißen sonst finde ich nachher nicht mehr so debian installer
old stable debian old stable so fertig wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht
habe sollte ich pxe booten können und bookworm installieren da bin ich mal
gespannt jetzt
Oh fuck, ich muss ins BIOS wieder.
Ich weiß nämlich nicht, wie ich ins Mood-Menü komme.
Ich muss immer direkt ins BIOS.
Ah, warum geht das nicht?
WTF?
Meine Tastatur hat nicht funktioniert.
Monkeys.
So, please.
Please restart.
Escape, escape, escape, escape.
Alter, was ist denn jetzt mit meiner KVM los, Mann?
Das hat halt echt keinen Bock, Alter.
reboot
Jetzt aber jetzt aber jetzt aber jetzt stöpsel ich da mal tastatur dran
Ok entfernt entfernt entfernt entfernt entfernt entfernt entfernt oder escape escape ist akku jetzt entert er schon setup sehr gut
Das bios ist übrigens auch ein bisschen verbuggt weil normalerweise würde man sagen man kann das hier auswählen aber
kann man nicht aber bringt nichts tut sich nichts
man fragt jetzt was save aber dann ändert sich nichts
boot
network
Es
Okay, mal gespannt ob ich jetzt mich nicht irgendwo vertippt habe
Bei meinem debian stable old stable gedöns
Irgendwo habe ich bestimmt stable drin stehen nicht mal als der ok
dem install all stable funzt funzt
ok
ok also ich glaube dass es jetzt okay language englisch europe in germany ja ist okay in german
Keyboard.
Jetzt müssen wir den Installer einmal durchklicken, aber das geht
aber Debian schnell. Das dauert nur 1-2 Minuten.
Habt ihr zufällig gesehen, dass er jetzt auch das Richtige gebootet hat?
Debian.
Perfekt.
Germany. Debian.
Nein.
So, das ist der Bookworm-Installer. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es da schon die Möglichkeit gab, direkt einen Sudo-User aufzusetzen.
Ach ne, ist immer noch das gleiche. Okay, hier.
Mein User, der Debian heißt.
Massive, super top secret Passwort.
Ihr ratet nicht, was ich für ein Passwort verwendet habe.
Best Practice Passwort ist das.
das entire disk 123456 korrekt das meist verbreitetste passwort auf der welt das
kann nicht schlecht sein und falls in one partition so viele leute wie das
benutzen können sich nicht irren
jetzt
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich sollte vielleicht mal
hier
mein Zeug
wieder einkommentieren, dass nächstes Wochenende
meine ganzen PXE-Images geupdatet werden.
Ich habe jetzt übrigens auch
ZFS-Boot-Menü drin.
Und das ist richtig high IQ.
Wisst ihr, wie ich das mache?
Guckt mal hier.
Ich emuliere...
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi.
Ich emuliere eine AMD 64 Kiste, um mir eine neue Version davon zu bauen.
Glaubt mir, das dauert richtig lange.
Der kompiliert zweieinhalb Stunden daran rum.
Ah ja gut, emuliere mal AMD 64 auf ARM64.
Aber das macht nichts, weil das passiert eh nachts.
Welche Linux-Distribution kann man gut für ein Microsoft Surface?
Ich hatte einen Surface. Auf der alten Arbeit, da habe ich Ubuntu drauf installiert.
Das ging ganz gut.
Das einzige Problem, was es damals gab, ist, dass beim Booten die Tastatur noch nicht eingeschaltet war.
Es ging nur um in der externen Tastatur zu booten.
Also wenn du Full-Disk-Encryption machen willst mit Unlock-Passwort eintippen.
Aber der Rest hat gut funktioniert.
Also wie gesagt, gab es keine Probleme.
Akkulaufzeit war miserabel.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe es nie im Akkubetrieb benutzt.
Ich habe es immer nur fest installiert an meinem Arbeitsplatz gehabt.
Wir wollen kein Debian Desktop.
Das wollen wir.
SSH und Standard Utilities.
Joho, was ist los?
sackt, wo du aktuell bist?
Oder willst du woanders hin, weil du mehr Kohle verdienst?
Es gibt ja Leute, die finden es eigentlich gar nicht schlecht,
wo sie sind, aber wissen,
da ist jetzt so das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht.
So, Debian Installation ist eigentlich auch so gut wie durch.
Als nächstes wird noch grub installiert und dann wird gebootet.
Jawoll, zack.
Wobei, Krab hat er sogar schon installiert.
So, also wollen wir mal.
Requesting reboot.
Jetzt muss ich hier ganz schnell wieder ins Bios.
Weil.
Das ist aber ziemlich ätzend.
Weil ich muss hier wieder umstellen.
Der soll Debian booten.
Bisschen broken hier.
Okay.
So.
Ah.
Da sind wir.
kann man bei aliexpress einstellen dass sie nicht so hartkopf viele mails schicken ganz
einfach mal aliexpress account ist geht nicht auf die normale e mail adresse sondern ich habe
dann extra extra account für das ganze zeug also ich lege mir für die meisten dienste eine extra
e mail account an und manche leite ich weiter auf meine haupt e mail und manche nicht ich habe
eine domain da werden einfach weitere accounts registriert easy für so ein
kram
ja gut dann wird robert neu so ein jahr ssh gucken ob es wieder 121 es hoffe ich
mal jetzt alles dinge andere ip jetzt muss ich gucken moment kurz in
meine router gucken ließ es debian 1 jetzt ist es 132 na gut fix ssh
Yes.
Massive.
Super Top Secret Passwort.
Moment.
SSH Copy ID.
Nur für den Fall der Fälle.
Ach Gott.
Das haben wir dann.
Falsche Key kopiert.
Whatever.
So.
Also.
Jetzt können wir diesen ganzen Krempel installieren.
Jetzt müssen wir aber vorher höchstwahrscheinlich.
Grafikkarte tut nicht.
Grafikkarte ist aber auch egal ob das tut.
Aber wir gehen trotzdem mal hier in die Packages rein und tragen mal diesen Kram ein, dass wir Non-Free-Firmware und sowas.
Das ist glaube ich auch für die Netzwerkkarte nicht verkehrt.
Ah, hier so.
Ach guck mal, hat er schon Main Non-Free-Firmware.
Das ist doch gut.
Warum ist das in dem alten Debian Bookworm drin und bei den neuen Debian nicht mehr?
Das ist nicht Libre genug oder was?
nicht lieb genug kann man auswählen habe ich nicht ausgewählt ja ich habe ein cloud image
installiert da war das natürlich nicht dabei ein custom installer ist im prinzip kein kreis
custom installer der die date einfach nur das db an cloud image auf die richtige platte
ok also hier search mst mst flint hieß das ding ab install mst flint jetzt sollten wir
aber nur wenigstens eine version haben die meine netzwerkkarte erkennt chat predictions geht's
jetzt endlich präge das gibt's da nicht
gab es damals diese diese module noch nicht okay wir machen nur für den fall
der Fälle. Contrib.
Non-Free.
Warum ist
das da standardmäßig immer Maus-Support
an? Das triggert mich hart.
Nee, gibt's wirklich nicht.
Okay, also LS,
PCI,
Crap. Melanox.
Den da.
Also, wie war das jetzt?
MST-Config.
Minus D, minus...
Nee, Q.
Boah, ey.
Alter.
Warum ist das so akane Wissenschaft
wieder, Mann?
Das soll doch mal irgendjemand checken, Mann.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier überhaupt?
Für eine Version.
Ja, da ist auf jeden Fall meine Grafikkarte dabei.
Dieser Fehler tritt häufig bei Unterricht...
Alter!
AI, laber nicht!
Laber nicht!
Veraltete Firmwareaktion.
Der Fehler mit Off-Boot, mit dem die Firmware auf Version 2.4.2.5 oder neuer...
Mal gucken, was ChatGPT dazu sagt.
ChatGPT sagt, ah, Classic.
Classic, sagt er ja.
Ich kann MST nicht starten.
Das gibt es nicht, dieses Programm bei mir.
Okay, ich glaube
Hier, du hast recht, Sarix
Ich glaube, du hast recht
Es wird echt Zeit
Es wird echt Zeit, die offiziellen Tools
Zu installieren, oder?
Ich glaube, es wird Zeit, die offiziellen
Tools zu installieren
Scheiß, scheiß
Open Source Tool
Es funktioniert
Warte mal, LS Mod
Crap
Ne, wie war das?
User Lib
Modules
Crap-IMST
Ne, gibt es nicht, okay
Memory Stick
Ja, ich hab doch 21.
Check, Firmware. Aha. Aha. Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also, wir checken jetzt die Firmware.
Wir glauben, Chat, wir glauben jetzt einfach mal,
aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
Der AI.
MST, Flint, minus D, Q.
Oh, er macht was.
Er macht was.
Ich habe bestimmt zu alte Firmware.
Das erzählt viel.
Das echte Problem.
The card was reflashed incorrectly.
Fix burn flash firmware.
Okay, okay.
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
Es wird Zeit.
Es wird Zeit für die offiziellen...
Es...
Es wird...
Es wird Zeit für die offiziellen Tools, okay?
Äh, Moment, was Älteres gibt's nicht?
Ah, hier, Archive-Versions.
Ah, 22 müsste auch gehen, oder?
Chat, der Support ist mit 26 rausgeflogen, richtig?
Also, Linux, Debian-based.
Dann aninstallen wir das nochmal.
Upt, Remove, ähm, MST.
Naja, alles wieder weg da.
x86 x64 ok copy link mk dir nun we get zack warum ist es in dem archiv der
Fuck.
Ta-X-F-Z-V.
Bam.
Ach so, das ist kein Debian-Package, das ist ein Installer.
Wie jetzt?
Inst...
Alter.
689 Zeilen?
Was ist das für ein Installer?
Was machen die denn da?
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Leute, 07, Install.
Ah, Kernel-Headers sind nicht installiert, okay.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, Leute.
Es hieß nicht Linux-Headers, sondern...
AMD64.
Okay, das halbe Internet wird installiert
Die checken Distro im Installer
Ey, dann muss ich wahrscheinlich
noch was älteres installieren
weil das ist Version, uralte Version.
Ah, guck mal da.
Er macht was.
Mit Windows wäre das nicht.
By the way, das wäre noch die letzte Option,
Leute. Wir installieren, wir installieren
Windows. Wir installieren Windows,
dass es funktioniert.
Oh, es funzt, es funzt, Leute.
MST Start.
Bam.
Dev MST.
Es funzt.
Okay, und wie geht das jetzt weiter?
MST? Ne, äh, äh, äh, MFT
heißt es jetzt. Ne.
Jetzt habe ich MST
Start gemacht. Und jetzt?
MLX!
MLX?
mlx config heißt es jetzt aha mlx config also ja
mlx kurz heißt ich mst configs und mx- d- q alter was zum teufel warum geht das nicht
nicht.
Fail to query device
configuration.
Okay, wir flashen jetzt.
Wir flashen jetzt, ich sag's euch,
wir flashen da jetzt die neueste Firma drauf.
Dentke.
Massive Dentke ist das. Richtig
hardcore Dentke.
Haben wir nicht eben was?
Äh, Flint.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht hier, dass das dann FFF hat?
Flint, Dump, Melanox.
Gibt's dann vielleicht eine...
Ich...
Trau ich mich?
Ich trau mich nicht, hier auf Bildersuche zu drücken.
Da fehlt was? Was fehlt da?
IDs?
Haben die...
Kann das... Weil das ist...
Ich hab ne Refurbished-Karte. Ich hab ne gebrauchte Karte gekauft.
Okay, muss man das?
Und was hat hier die AI nochmal zugesagt?
Vielleicht Custom-Firmware drauf.
Ich flash das Ding jetzt nochmal neu.
Was?
Dies deutet auf eine OEM-Variante.
Komm, Chat-GPT.
Wichtig, dass du...
Das ist ein bekannter Fehler
in älteren Firmware-Versionen.
Okay.
Suche bei Dell Support?
What?
Schön, dass du da bist.
Hovedes.
Wieder ein Klassiker.
Did you try a firmware update with... Moment, man kann so die Leter das runter? Boah, das ist ja richtig high IQ.
Sag bloß, sag bloß.
Natürlich nicht.
Wo bekommt man ein MLX ab her?
Melanox Update Utility
Boah, das ist super
Arkane-Wissenschaft, Alter
Linux
x64
Das ist bestimmt ein Go-Binary
oder sowas, irgendwas, was
Ich wehgette das jetzt einfach
Ich muss bestimmt eine ältere Version verwenden, weil es nicht mehr supported ist.
File, MLX up.
Dynamically linked.
MLX up.
Okay.
Der.
Available, not available.
Okay, whatever.
Okay, da gibt er tatsächlich irgendwas aus.
Das passt auch irgendwie, ja.
No matching image found.
Geil.
Okay.
Please refer firmware downloads.
Melanox X3 Ethernet.
Adapter Firmware Burning Instructions.
Okay, Current Version.
Äh.
Oh, Chat, jetzt müsst ihr mir helfen.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Was ist das?
Sind das die...
XCA?
XCAA? Das gibt's bei mir gar nicht.
Was ist das?
x-card
x-card ok also anscheinend brauchen wir das
anscheinend brauchen wir das, das ist komplettes Gerate was ich jetzt hier mache
PSID
das stimmt guck mal
das ist die
Release
3, 4
September 2017
Was sind die alten hier?
November 2013
Ja, ich gebe zu, das ist schon ein bisschen
ältere Netzwerkkarte, ja
Okay, wie flasht man das jetzt?
Unzip?
Unzip? Unzip?
Was ein Dateiname, Alter!
Was ein Dateiname, Mann!
Kann man das jetzt irgendwie hiermit?
MLX up?
Kann man das damit irgendwie flashen?
Hatten die nicht sogar ein Leitfaden?
du meinst hier?
Adapter Burning Instructions.
Ja.
Download the MFT Package.
Install MFT. Download the
correct Firmware.
MST Start.
MST
Status.
Warum gibt es denn MLX
ab, wenn man das damit machen soll? Da blickt doch
kein Mensch durch, ey.
Burn the Firmware to the card.
Splint minus D.
Device name Binary Image.
Burn.
Chat, Chat, Prage.
Wir müssen jetzt einmal kurz,
paar Sekunden einmal pragen
in Chat, dass ich meine Netzwerkkarte
nicht schrotte, okay?
Weil die Chancen bei der
Firma Flash, wenn es nicht stimmt, die sind ja hoch.
Die sind ja hoch, gell?
Prage, chat, prage.
Wann kommt dein Ukraine-Nass?
Siehst du es? Das ist das U-Crew-NAS.
Aber das ist nicht das U-Crew-NAS, was angeschlossen ist gerade.
Das ist ein Miniforum-NAS, was angeschlossen ist.
Was mir von den Specs besser gefällt.
Okay.
Also.
Was machen wir jetzt?
D, Binary Image.
Binary Image ist ja dann wahrscheinlich das hier.
Burn.
Bam.
Okay.
Burn Process will not be failed safe.
No checks will be performed.
All Flash including the image will be overwritten.
If this process fails, computer may remain in inoperable state.
Nein, der Computer vielleicht nicht.
Die Netzwerkkarte.
Okay.
Yes
Gib ihm, gib ihm
Okay
Ah, muss man jetzt rebooten?
oder muss man jetzt einmal
einmal einmal komplett strom abziehen mache ich jetzt sagt ich ziehe jetzt einfach strom
gesteck heraus ok strom war draußen und wieder eingeschaltet sieht eigentlich so
auch die Arbeit von einem Devon nicht wirklich.
Wach auf der Arbeit.
Gefühlt nur noch Jammel, Files und Terraform.
Ich bin eher
Jammel-Engineer mittlerweile.
Jetzt bricked.
Ich habe zwei Netzwerkkarten.
Eine Onboard, die geht auf jeden Fall.
Oh.
Okay.
Er hat schon mal gebootet.
Oh, Jet, das Ding ist nicht erreichbar.
Okay, doch. Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Alles gut, alles gut, alles gut.
Über welche Netzwerkkarte sind wir jetzt eigentlich gerade hier am Start?
Das ist die Melanox-Karte. Okay.
Hat funktioniert.
Es hat funktioniert.
Jet, ich bin gerade ein wenig verwirrt.
Ach hier, da hatte ich es rumliegen
Achso, MST
Oh, ich habe schon gedacht, die Karte ist kaputt, ey
3, 4
Nice
Okay, Dump
Ne, wie war das? Flint?
Oh, fuck, meine History ist weg
Flint?
Äh
OK, die Guids sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer noch FFF.
Da weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das schlimm ist, ja.
mlx ab
ok ok konflikt wie war das konflikt
msc config das war das richtige
jetzt ist es mlx config
was hat er das ist immer noch kaputt was hat er denn für schmerzen die kann man aber auch setzen
ja aber auf was?
Auf ne Random Grid ID? Okay.
Hier gibt's einen Thread.
Was?
Ja
Edit the ini-File
Moment, Moment, langsam
Langsam, langsam, langsam
Ich will ja erstmal nur PXE-Boot einschalten
Da hab ich doch hier so, genau, hier gab's doch so ein Guide
So
MLX-Config-Device
UEFI-enabled
Wir können das theoretisch
Ja, das funzt ja nicht
Das funzt ja nicht
Weil ich das nicht lesen kann
Weil ich ja nicht querien kann
Configuration
Meine Güte, also mal ohne Scheiß, Leute
Ich glaube, das ist eines der abartigsten Dinger
Die mir je untergekommen sind, ey
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum so
Enterprise-Hardware, warum das immer so
ein Pain in the Ass ist, Alter.
Okay, kann ich jetzt einfach so was hier
sagen? Schauen wir mal.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Dentke.
Unknown Parameter.
Ja.
Das stimmt, sonst kauft kein.
Melanox CX3 enable SR-IO4.
Auto-Config.
Making Melanox.
melanox hier guck mal hier gibt es einen forum thread
kann denn der hier sein kram überhaupt
ok
Ja, Moment mal, das habe ich auch früher, das hat doch nicht funktioniert bei mir.
Hä? Moment mal, Moment.
Start of Guide.
Get.
die Firmware soll ich
getten.
Das ist eine andere Firmware.
Ach, das ist die Dualport-Karte.
Genau.
Der Support-Macher sagt
Classic.
No matching image found.
Da ist doch schon mal irgendwas faul.
Da ist doch schon mal irgendwas hier nicht richtig.
Da stimmt doch schon mal irgendwas nicht.
Was ist denn der MLX FW Manager schon wieder?
Das ist die neueste, die es gibt, ne?
Das ist Windows-Geschiss?
Juckt nicht.
Monk hat...
Moment, wir haben doch die Firmware schon geupdatet.
Haben wir vielleicht die falsche Firmware?
Vielleicht die falsche Firmware?
Ach, gucke mal.
Gucke mal da.
Ein Inni?
Wir haben die falsche Firmware?
Guck mal, bei Melanox gibt's die noch
WTF
Meine Güte, Alter
Wie kompliziert willst du das eigentlich noch machen?
Okay, okay, okay
Ich muss das mal lesen, kurz hier
Connect Custom Firmware
Ich will keine, Leute, ich will keine Custom Firmware
Ich will einfach eine Firmware, wo ich
PXE-Boot enablen kann
Ich seh schon, das ist High-IQ-Shit, Mann.
Modify the configuration.
Nee, nee.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt bei Melanox nochmal nach Downloads, okay?
Oh fuck, das leitet jetzt auf Nvidia um
No
Aber Chat, das sieht besser aus, oder?
Guck mal, weil das heißt auch so
Wie meine Firmware heißt
Seht ihr das?
Okay, wir flashen jetzt nochmal
Wir flashen jetzt nochmal
Heißt das... Das heißt doch...
Moment, das ist...
Äh...
Chat, ich hab nix gesagt.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Ich hab das Richtige installiert.
Guck mal. Das heißt schon so.
Ich hab das Richtige.
Alles gut. Alles richtig.
Ähm...
ich kann auch nichts anderes machen als dumm fragen stellen
habt ihr jedenfalls nicht modified ja genau die ob wir es lieh
ok also wir haben das richtige wir haben das richtige gepasht ja
Ja, wir...
Verify manually, hab ich.
Das Problem ist halt,
dass das...
Sind die...
Das Problem ist halt,
dass das nicht...
Fail to query device configurate.
Warum?
Chat, meint ihr vielleicht, meine MFT-Sachen
sind immer noch zu neu.
Die verwenden hier irgendwas von
1.17 oder so.
Soll ich nochmal was älteres installieren?
Hier macht der irgendwelche komischen Dinger.
Wir haben noch schönes...
Problems making.
Known issue.
Ja, geil.
Okay, guck dir mal.
So müsste das eigentlich aussehen.
So müsste die Ausgabe aussehen, wenn es funktioniert.
Ja, ne, hab ich gerade. Das hatten wir vorher auch schon. Das bringt nichts.
die solution ist zu generieren mit dem modifizierten
mxf file you can use with what
aber ich will doch erstmal nur px boot in ebel
Okay, wie gesagt, Chat, wir können immer noch die Onboard-Karte benutzen.
Okay, das Bookmark ich mir mal.
Das werden wir wahrscheinlich brauchen.
Ich will ja S-A-I-O-V, will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich will ja hier Following Versions.
Okay, okay, was hab ich noch mal?
422, okay, das ist zu alt.
Ich, ich, ich, ich, ohne Scheiß,
ich installiere jetzt 417.
Dann geht's, dann geht's vielleicht. Okay.
Chatgear. Nvidia.
Äh.
Das hatten wir schon.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ne, ne, ich will,
ich will hier, das da, das da, ne.
Ja, das da.
Ihr archiv hier lts beste 422 417 so beste linux
baby an based
x4 das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich so alt dass es auf einem db an nicht mehr funktioniert war wetten dass ich das wird wieder richtig
paintchamp
Mft kann man das an den soll ich habe doch dann an install skript gesehen
Was ein...
Leute, aber ohne Scheiß, das ist richtig massiver
Pain in the ass, ey
ETF
Was ein Krampf, man
Und ich bin übrigens auch unschlüssig
Ob wir das hinkriegen
Ich hab da wirklich meine Zweifel
Ob das funktioniert am Ende
Äh
Achso
Ich hab vielleicht das richtige
Ich hab Install und nicht Uninstall gemacht
Ja, wirklich?
Oh
Ups
Das ist aber nett, dass du es nicht removest.
Das ist aber sehr nett von dir,
dass du meinen User Lip64 nicht removest.
Äh, was ist hier? Lock.
Was hat er denn jetzt?
Was ist das Problem jetzt?
Was?
Äh, ich glaube,
mein Kernel ist zu neu, oder?
Kann es sein, mein Curdle ist zu neu?
Der funktioniert mit dem alten Chip nicht mehr?
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Nee, Windows benutze ich nicht.
Debian ist zu neu.
Was ist denn mit meiner Musik?
Ich brauche Mario Kart Musik hier.
Kann es sein, dass 4.17 die Kernelversion...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Weil das, was funktioniert hat...
Das, was funktioniert hat, ist 4.22.
Nee, nee, das ist was anderes.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt noch funktioniert wenigstens.
Ob ich irgendwie broken ist.
Okay.
Also, 17 Pfunds, ne?
20 20 ok 20 probieren wir jetzt
ich teste jetzt einfach mal, random, try and error, 20 was 20.1 linux, guck mal die hatten sogar noch
BSD-Version mal.
Debian-Based.
Okay, das wird...
Warte mal.
Q.
Warum ist das fail to query?
Das ist so scheiße, man.
Uninstall. So.
Also, hier.
Weget.
taisen mfx xfz mft 20 mft 20 install hat alter
das ist zu alt mein köln ist zu alt zu neu
Also wir müssen das irgendwie mit dieser dummen 20er Version zum Laufen bekommen.
Chat, so langsam gehen mir die Ideen aus. Wenn ihr noch Ideen habt, nur her damit.
Ja, das ist zu alt.
Was hätten wir da noch zu sehen?
Okay, Leute, mit 2...
Mit 2,26 ist es rausgeflogen.
Nach 2,26 ist es rausgeflogen.
Das heißt,
hier müsste es
eigentlich noch drin sein.
Out-Out-Table.
Lässt sich die Firma über Windows flashen?
Die Firma lässt sich auch unter Linux flashen.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass es irgendwie keine Info...
Ey Leute, soll ich Windows installieren?
Warum nicht?
Ich installiere Windows.
Warum musst du nicht rebooten?
Für Kernelmodule musst du nicht rebooten.
Du kannst es loaden, unloaden.
glaube ich zumindest dann aber schon andere probleme gerade
Muss muss ich dafür reboot eigentlich nicht eigentlich nicht
A xfz
Mft
20 install
Ja, aber der kommt ja noch nicht mal zum Installieren, Leute.
Der kommt ja noch nicht mal zum Installieren.
Okay.
MST Start.
Das funktioniert schon mal.
Das hat schon mal funktioniert.
Query.
Ha!
Da ist der Support entfernt worden.
Mit der Version ist der Support weg.
Wir hatten doch nix Packages.
Warte mal, wir hatten doch hier irgendwo...
Vier müsste es geben, ja.
Okay, Chat, Chat, warte mal, warte mal kurz
Moment, Moment
Äh, was hab ich, was hab ich jetzt zuletzt installiert?
Die da, ne?
Uninstall
Wir hatten doch hier
MS
Ach ne, ich hab
Warte mal, Bash
Nix
Okay, sudo apt install curl.
Aber installieren kann man kurz mal nix, so als wie man den ganzen anderen Krempl installieren
kann.
Heute wollen sie es wissen, ja.
Nix, wie konnte man den Kram hier?
WTF, alter?
WTF, Alter?
Äh.
Achso, ich muss mal einen ausloggen.
Ja, auf.
Let's go.
Nix OS.
guck mal das ist 417
417 war ja die Version die eigentlich gut funktionieren sollte
MST
jetzt heißt es
jetzt heißt es MST
auf einmal
Sudo
minus D
NSPCI, Kret-I, wie oft ich das heute schon
beschrieben hab, ey.
Minus D.
Okay, das ist das gleiche Problem.
Also, irgendwas stimmt mit
meiner Netzwerkkarte nicht.
Irgendwas ist da
im Arsch.
Irgendwas ist da im Arsch.
Weil der das nicht querien kann.
Hast du...
Mittlerweile habe ich sie geflasht, ja.
Guck, kann ich dir auch zeigen, dass ich sie mittlerweile geflasht habe.
Achso, ja gut, ich habe MSD gerade nicht erzählt.
So, wir probieren es jetzt nochmal mit der 26.
Blick langsam echt einmal durch.
Äh, Old Version.
Also 26 war kaputt.
Linux only.
Na, das kann doch nur gut sein.
wahrscheinlich gab es dann ein bug und dann müssen wir noch mal googeln warum das warum
das nicht funzt also warum das immer sagt could not get ob das ob dieser mein guiz liegt keine
ahnung ok install ob das jetzt funktioniert hier ob man kann wieder zu
alles war sie gut aus sie gut aus sie gut aus excel excel excel mst start
minus q okay es geht aber das war das falsche das war das falsche mlx config
okay das geht nicht warum nicht fällt da ist doch garantiert irgendwas
Ist das Flint?
Äh.
Da ist doch garantiert irgendwas
mit meiner Karte im Arsch.
Was macht der hier?
Können ja mal gucken.
Das heißt wieder anders, ey.
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, wie das wieder heißt.
Unloading.
Modul.
Und jetzt loadet das wieder.
Da wird schon das richtige geladen sein.
Wir können nochmal rebooten.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Wir rebooten mal schnell nochmal.
Windows Failed.
ja das ist auch schon mal ein reißer melanox er gibt es im prinzip das problem
was ich auch habe aber das hatten wir schon mal da stand ja nichts da stand
ja nichts drin
das hatten wir auch schon vorhand
Ich würde das vielleicht mal lesen.
Bellanox, was sagen die hier?
Da landen wir jetzt bei Nvidia auf der Seite.
Geil.
Ähm.
Was zum...
Ich muss irgendwelche Inifiles editieren?
Was?
Das glaube ich jetzt aber nicht, oder?
Ne, ne, ne.
Also ich muss ja erstmal meine...
Ich muss erstmal meine Karte doch überhaupt auslesen können, bevor ich da irgendwelche Inifiles editiere.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt.
Ich mach das jetzt so, wie das hier steht.
Aber mit dem Unterschied, ich will eigentlich PXE-Boot enablen.
Ähm
So, was hatten wir jetzt hier zuletzt?
Linux only
Ähm, die da, gell? Die hatten wir zuletzt
Richtig?
Ist aber auch egal
MST-Status
MST-Start
Query
er geht immer noch okay gut dann nicht also okay was was muss ich machen hier
blind dmst die weiß inny jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ach so
Lestmp.ini
Da steht der Scheiß wirklich drin.
Okay, nice.
ini.ini
Beste, beste, beste Datei.
PXE?
Ich will fucking PXE aktivieren!
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen!
Gut.
Ah, ah, ah!
Ah!
Sarix
Leute, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich kann das nicht setzen
Oh, Moment, oh, sorry
Ihr wollt mich nicht verarschen, oder?
Doch, ihr wollt mich verarschen
Chat
Was, von was sprecht ihr?
Der hat da Nummern bei den Guids
Das stimmt wohl
Ich könnte mir einfach dem seine Guids klauen
Wir resetten das jetzt mal
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal, was hier steht
Reset Configuration for Device
By the way, was ist eigentlich hier?
Dev MST
Warum gibt es da eigentlich zwei Dinger?
PCI-CR und PCI-Conf
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen
Kann ich nicht auch einfach sagen
Wir machen einfach beides, Leute.
So, und jetzt
Reboot.
Und dann soll ich Query.
Jetzt haben wir die Netzwerkkarte
Resetted.
Hier,
HiAQ-Chat kann ja schon mal rausfinden,
wie man die Guids setzt.
Das flasht man bestimmt
auch über die Inni, hä?
You can reflash
the firmware. Das habe ich doch schon gemacht.
Oh, der ist wieder da. Das ging aber schnell.
Nicht update, uptime.
Aber der hat rebooted.
Okay, MST Start.
Cool.
Fuck.
Alter.
Geht immer neu.
Okay, also als nächstes.
Okay.
Äh
Was macht das hier jetzt?
Achso, das ist zum Flashen
Das ist zum Flashen, da muss das Binary hin
Ja gut, das hatten wir ja schon.
Okay, Chat.
Sarix, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Ich hoffe, du hast es nicht, Chat-GPT.
Okay, so funktioniert es schon mal.
Es muss Minus Minus sein, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Tufi Tufi Arguments
Aha
Angeblich gut
Aber muss
Kann das sein, dass man hier sagen muss,
Guit?
Alter.
Wo ist hier der Einzelklammer?
Und das wird es wahrscheinlich sein, ja.
aber nur gut
aber eine güte wie ist das richtige kommando für
das stimmt überhaupt nicht
die ei labert einfach gerade wieder
Es geht dahinter
Stimmt Quotes hast recht
So man muss gut dahinter schreiben, okay
Also, das habe ich doch schon mal richtig gesehen
Greed
So, wir können tatsächlich die Quotes entfernen
No command found
Geil
Wo soll ich SG hinschreiben?
Äh
Das ist ja auch wieder richtig eklig gemacht.
Meinst du?
Da muss SG hinten dran?
Wirklich?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay.
Flint, Zed, Guids, Melanox.
Zed, Guids und Mech.
Also.
Wie jetzt?
Hä?
Ich check's nicht.
Was will das? Was wollen die mir sagen?
Chat, das haben wir doch schon ausprobiert.
Das hat nicht funktioniert, oder?
Ja, ja, gut, dass es
invalid Syntax ist.
Aber
das hatte ich doch oben schon mal, oder?
Genau so.
No command found, sagt er dann
Also irgendwie check ich auch die
Ah
OCR, was zum
Was
Ich will die Mac nicht setzen.
Was habe ich denn jetzt gemacht?
Warte mal.
Minus Q?
Ne, hat sich aber nichts getan jetzt.
Alter, ist das...
Oh.
Noch SG?
Ah, es macht was.
Es macht was.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt ist es bricked.
Jetzt ist es komplett broken.
Oh, ne.
Oh, oh.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Er muss neu flashen.
Flashchamp.
Das muss ich mir bookmarken,
dass das nachher noch weiß.
Zack.
Okay.
Ach, guck mal.
Ich habe Guids am Start.
Geht denn jetzt das andere Kommando auch?
Ach, Scheiße.
Das geht immer noch nicht.
Okay, was macht man jetzt mit dieser komischen
Inni hier?
ETF, Alter, was ist das hier?
Ich, RM, Inni, ich mach das nochmal mit der Inni hier
Inni
Das klingt nicht an, Lilux, ich wette mit euch, dass das Fonds auch
Soll ich nochmal rebooten?
Ach, haben wir einen Reboot
Ups
Und jetzt machen wir nochmal
Jetzt machen wir nochmal das hier
Entweder Emotes.
Äh.
MST, Start.
Was bringt es eine Netzwerkkarte zu flashen?
Zum Beispiel, dass man PXE...
Oh Gott, das funzt nicht
Dass man PXE-Booten erst auf EUV aktivieren kann
Das ist das, was ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit vorhabe
Ich installiere nachher Windows
Oh du Scheiße
Vielleicht geht es dann
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es daran liegt
Ohne Mist, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das ein Problem von Linux ist
Das ist irgendwas mit meiner Netzwerkkarte
Die haben das Ding irgendwie einmal verkehrt geflasht
Oder sowas
MLX Burn.
Das habe ich auch noch nicht verwendet.
Ja, Leute, es gibt MLX Up,
Blind und MLX Burn.
Ja, was?
Da blickt doch keiner mehr durch.
Müsste in VSD was drinnen stehen?
Warte mal, hier hat doch irgendeiner...
Chat, wo war denn das?
Irgendeiner hat doch hier...
war sein output gepostet war das hier nicht
vst was ist eine vst
virtual switch das ist das habe ich nicht
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich habe den gerade jetzt auch mal resettet.
EXP-ROM-UFI, was?
Moment, nicht PXE, EXP?
Aber das ging ja nicht, weil ich mein Kram nicht listen konnte.
Wait a minute, was ist denn eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen PCI-C0 und dem anderen?
Dann muss ich vielleicht das andere nochmal resetten.
MST Start.
Dev MST.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Und das andere?
Geil, super!
Anderen Parameter
Ja, weil es nicht auslesen kann
also mit dem reset hat schon mal auch nichts funktioniert funktioniert
ich glaube die ei labert wieder
Ich glaube, die AI labert für der dummes Zeuge.
Ja, macht's auch.
Das ist Bullshit, ey.
Also ich bin jetzt echt langsam ratlos, außer Windows zu entstehen.
Warum kann er die Konfiguration nicht querien?
Das ist garantiert irgendwas ganz simples
Wie man muss eine spezielle Version nehmen
Und dann funzt es
Die Karte ist nicht dead
Ich bin gerade per SSH eingeloggt
Mit dieser Karte
Wie soll die dead sein?
Vielleicht innerlich, ja das bin ich auch langsam.
Aber ich bin ja wirklich nicht der Einzige, der die Probleme hat, so wie es aussieht, ne?
Die Karte ist active, das ist das Problem. Quatsch.
Das ist doch nicht das Problem.
Unresolved GitHub Issue.
Okay.
DB an Bullseye.
Okay, lass mal kurz was gucken.
Äh...
Ach, ETH-Tool ist nicht drauf.
ETH.
ETH-Tool gibt es doch schon seit 30 Jahren.
Okay.
Auch gut.
Aha.
Ja, ja, das sieht tatsächlich so aus wie...
Okay, die 2425 ist wohl ein Problem.
Supports EEPROM-Access.
What the hell?
Das ist schon wieder echt Next Level Shit.
Ja, jetzt ist genau das gleiche Problem.
Hab ich auch.
geil nice top klaus demnächst ich brauche mir einfach eine eigene firma
ok
das funzt ja bestimmt bei mir auch nicht
fail to query device configuration
ja genau
ok man muss wirklich flint zum dumpen und dann neu burnen
Ah, Moment, man braucht...
Alter, es gibt auch noch zwei verschiedene
Firmware-Versionen. Es gibt eine MLX und eine
BIN-Version.
Ich dreh durch.
Okay, the solution is to generate an image with a modified INI, but the MLX file you
can use with that is older than the latest available bin.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
ok also das ist ich will ja zwei sachen ich will erst einschalten und ich will px e boot
enablen.
Ich hab zu viele
Sachen hier offen.
Ich blicke
grad nicht mal durch.
Also das mit dem Reset und so, das hat alles nicht funktioniert.
Gucken wir mal in die Innie rein.
Ja, will ich.
ich will ja px e booten können damit sonst kann ich es ja vergessen
das steht hier gar nicht trainer
ich habe zu viel zeug hier auf ich habe zu viel zeug hier auf ich blick
kann er durch hat man also das was war das hier ja hier genau
dass da ja gut aber ich brauche diese mlx mlx firma
Und wo kriege ich die MLX-Firmware her?
Would you kindly share this MLX-File?
Alter, soll ich mir wirklich eine
Firmware für meine Netzwerkkarte von irgendeinem
komischen Blogspot runterladen?
Alter!
Jetzt wird es aber langsam echt zu abgedreht, Mann.
Scheiß, Alter, Scheiß.
Scheiß.
Ich hab jetzt ein Gitter-Post.
Okay.
Das Reddit-Post
has a link to
a...
Ey, ne, das, das...
Boah, ey, das ist ja absolut grausam, man.
Das ist ja absolut grausam, Alter.
Bitte, ich will einfach nur PXE-Boot für meine Netzwerkkarte aktivieren.
wisst ihr, ey, ohne Scheiß,
ich kauf mir einfach ne neue.
STH ist gut,
das Problem ist, die fehlt die Firma-Version.
Wart mal, wir hatten doch noch,
wir hatten doch noch einen anderen STH-Link.
Wir hatten doch noch einen anderen.
Ich will...
Unter anderem, unter anderem, ja?
Unter anderem für PXE-Mut.
Okay, okay, okay.
Guck mal.
Hier hat irgendein Dude seine Firma
Moment, die benutzen was?
Die benutzen MFT?
Okay, Chat, ich glaube, es wird Zeit, dass wir Proxmox installieren.
Ich brauche eine VM auf der Kiste, damit ich noch ältere Debian-Versionen ausprobieren kann.
Moment, wo hat denn jetzt dieses MLX-File her?
Hier das hier das richtige firma
Ach guck mal da ist das melanox fall okay
Okay, okay, okay
chat egal wie probiert probieren das mal
spc
was macht ihr hier im skript das brauche wir machen das wir machen das selbst basic info
such as good.
Wobei, das Skript ist gar nicht so verkehrt, ne?
Was macht das hier? Das erzeugt nur Backups?
Oder was hier? Das sagt...
Ach, das sagt hier, was man machen muss.
Im Endeffekt
dampft das hier nur Zeug.
Ja, das können wir tatsächlich...
Aber das ist natürlich
mein Skript.
Okay, ID.
ID ist 1 bei mir.
Und dann können wir das hier ausführen.
Okay, weil jetzt haben wir hier
eine Flint
HW-Info.
Ja, okay.
Failed, failed, failed.
Da ist nichts. Failed?
Okay.
original firmware in die original firmware zeug okay was auch immer ich hier am sehen bin
original firmware in die haben wir alles so okay und jetzt dass da
Okay, Firmware Archive
Also, hier
Äh
Wo habe ich den Krempel hier gerade?
Das Flint Query klappt schon die ganze Zeit
Was nicht klappt ist
Das da
Das klappt nicht
Äh
Welche soll ich editieren?
Die da.
Ini.
Okay. Und da soll ich
unter
HCA
das da schreiben.
Sag mal, gibt es vielleicht
Mellanox Ini
PXE Boot?
Kann man das da vielleicht irgendwie eintragen?
das funktioniert ja nicht
melanox in label pxe
Ja, so sieht's aus, wenn's funktioniert.
krass was sind das guck mal hier man kann sich da
kann sich so auch die firmen herunterladen lassen
Ja, das ist ja nice.
Hätte ich das mal vorher gewusst.
Äh.
Na gut, aber das brauche ich ja nicht.
Also das habe ich ja schon.
Aber nee, nee, nee, das hatten wir ja schon.
Das funzt ja nicht, weil
er ja sagt, no matching image
found.
Äh, Sarix, hast du das
irgendwo gefunden?
Oder ist das
AI-Shit? Weil mehr AI-Kram
brauchen wir echt nicht.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Nvidia Documentation.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht,
dass das funzt.
Wir machen jetzt,
Wir machen jetzt erst nochmal das Ding hier fertig.
Also das habe ich hinzugefügt.
4, 2, 6 supportet das nicht mehr.
Das ist richtig.
Deswegen haben wir auch nicht 4, 2, 6.
Sondern 4, 2, 5.
Okay.
Also habe ich die jetzt
richtig editiert?
Ja, passt.
Und jetzt muss das
geburnt werden.
MLX burn.
FW release
MLX.
Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich
einen Punkt Slash davor machen, dass er das findet.
MLX,
Conf,
Any, Write, Image, FW, Connect.
Äh.
Also überhaupt kein...
Ach so.
Ey, was ist
missing?
Was ist missing?
Wie wärs, wenn er mir sagt, was?
If.
Alter.
Okay, äh, äh, was, was für ein Image-Generation-Tool?
ok
in linux package oder
laber nicht das mick tool nicht findet mick tool
Okay.
MFT 4.10.
Das schreibt der Dude hier auch.
Der Dude schreibt das hier auch.
Der schreibt auch was von
4.10.
Achso.
Och man, Alter.
Okay, ich muss
Ich muss doch, weil das lässt sich
Das lässt sich jetzt auf dem Körnel nicht mehr installieren
Ähm
Da, XFZV
Ne, wir installieren uns keinen Proxmox
Ich installiere jetzt Wirtmanager
Und wir hauen uns dort eine Debian-VM drauf
Weil wir brauchen halt irgendwas
Was alt ist, was funktioniert
Äh
Äh, warum funktioniert das?
Chat, wir haben Sachen installiert, die waren viel neuer, die gingen nicht.
Äh.
Jetzt hat er keine Netzwerkkarte mehr gefunden.
MST Stopp.
Start.
Das könnte jetzt wirklich an der alten Körner-Version liegen.
Ja, äh, Reboot.
Aber das wird's wahrscheinlich nicht fixen.
Boah.
Das ist eine Melanox Connect X3 oder sowas.
Ja siehste
Siehste
Das hat halt kein Plan
Die AI labert dummes Zeug
Läuft die Karte jetzt
Wir haben eine alte Version gefunden
Die theoretisch
das Flaschen erlaubt.
Aber
es funzt
nicht.
Weil das no
such file or directory.
Okay, was für eine
Chat, was für eine Debian-Version.
Was hat
der hier gehabt?
der 2023 gehabt? Das müsste
doch schon Bookworm gewesen sein, oder?
Und so.
Das müsste doch schon eigentlich Bookworm gewesen sein.
Mik-Tool.
Find, Mik
Moment, das ist
Aber da ist es doch
User bin Mik
Wisst ihr was wir machen?
CP, High IQ
wir kopieren uns das raus.
Und jetzt
gehen wir
auf
die Version, die eigentlich noch
mit am besten funktioniert hat.
Moment, die alte müssen wir erstmal uninstallen.
Uninstall.
Okay.
Und jetzt gehen wir da rein und sagen Install.
MST Start.
Okay.
Image Burn.
image generation tool missing okay da ist es das sollte eigentlich also cp mic user bin aber kommt
Okay, das muss anscheinend zusammenpassen.
Das ist ein Scheiß, Alter.
Okay, ähm, wir...
Aninstall... okay, aninstallen wir da.
Oh, was ist hier? Was hat er hier am Start?
Skriptors?
Was?
Moment.
Das ist was ganz was anderes.
Moment, es gibt noch eine extra
Firmenversion von Lenovo.
Jetzt können die mich mal...
Also.
Komm mal, der hat auch Guids.
F, F, F, F, F, F.
Was bin ich jetzt hier sehend gerade?
Ah, seine Firmware-Version.
was was ist das jetzt hier was zum die posten einfach irgendwelche random sachen
oder warten dann den leuten blicken dadurch was ist das hier schon wieder
So, er hat angefangen zu kaufen.
Connected network card instead.
Er hat jetzt auch eine andere Netzwerkkarte genommen.
Na geil.
Nee, eigentlich ist das eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich
Ja, Moment, das hatten wir ja schon, dann funktioniert es ja nicht.
Moment.
Man kann das auslesen?
Aus dem...
Ich hätte es gar nicht runterladen müssen.
Alter, das ist so widersprüchlich alles, man.
Äh.
Mal erstmal installieren.
Das ist alles so widersprüchlich.
Ich blick da mal durch
Das ist kein Open Device
Dev, MSC
Was hat der hier?
Ja Moment, man kann die
Ich hätte mir die Firma gar nicht runterladen müssen
weil er den Kram hier dampfen kann.
Guck mal hier, der hat es runtergeladen.
Und jetzt noch das Orgie...
Naja.
Das andere hätte man gar nicht gebraucht.
Ich bin auch verwirrt.
Glaubt mir, ich bin auch verwirrt.
Ich versuche meine Netzwerkkarte zu flashen.
Und eigentlich will ich
PXE enablen
und SAIOV enablen,
was angeblich geht.
Ja.
So, und da wo muss ich das jetzt
Wo musste ich das jetzt drunter kopieren?
HCA
Aber das hat jetzt ja nichts gebracht
Weil ich es nicht burnen kann
Jetzt war mal MLX Burn, war das.
MLX Burn.
Aber, aber...
Jetzt ist hier das Original, okay.
Aber das Image Generaten hat er nicht gefunden.
cannot auto detect device kann ich sagen b dev ms
kann ich das einfach weglassen und dann flashen
Image Generation Tool
is missing.
Das geht jetzt wieder nicht.
Pay to open in order to convert to new format.
Oh.
Okay, ich installiere mir jetzt eine 4M
mit noch einem älteren Linux und dann zählen wir 4.10.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich bin eigentlich schon mittlerweile so weit,
dass ich sagen würde, ich nehme eine andere
Netzwerkkarte.
Windows, okay.
Not found?
Ah.
Achso.
Melanox
Mig Tool.
Krab Mig.
Äh.
Warte mal, wo ist das?
Wo ist dieses?
Äh, Finn, du hast...
Die Netzwerkkarte funktioniert, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Die Netzwerkkarte... Ich will die Netzwerkkarte flashen, um ein paar Features zu aktivieren.
Ja, das haben wir doch!
was ist das hier?
Zeug.
Was?
Weg mit ihm.
Ja siehste?
Ja das hatten wir auch.
Firma Backup.
Haben wir gemacht.
Flashing.
anzippte firma downloadet von melanox change the file extensions von bim to mlx
ok ok
das ding ist ich will ja custom configs applying
Das ist ja nur...
Das ist ja nur, wie er die Firmware flashen kann.
Firmware flashen haben wir auch schon hingekriegt.
Ähm.
Das Problem ist, ich muss jetzt...
Kann man vielleicht...
Jetzt mal ganz doof, ne?
Ähm...
Wie hab ich nochmal geflasht?
Äh...
Bin?
Hier.
Blind? Probier das doch mal.
Blind minus D?
Ach, nee.
Ja, das mit dem Burn-Funds nicht.
Weil das Image-Generation-Tool
ist missing.
Warum ist da auf Instagram was?
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Wir installieren jetzt
App Install
Wirt Manager, KVM.
Oder was man da alles für installieren muss.
Bam.
wir installieren jetzt wird manager fahren uns dort noch was ist ein db an releases
was gab es denn vor book von bulls
installieren uns mal schnell in dem jahren bulls ein paar passen die netzwerk karte
Through mit Version
10.
Ubuntu 16.4.
Ah, das ist verkehrt.
Das Ding ist nur, Leute,
ich will ja nicht die Firma updaten.
Ich will ja
also
ich will ja
das editieren und dann burnen.
Das einfach nur Firma update war easy.
der nimmt auch eine custom in die wo nimmt er eine custom in die hier sehe
ich nichts von inny der macht im ganzen post keine
er macht hier nichts mit in die falls echt wo wo macht er was mit in die falls
Ach, das kommt noch da unten.
Ich hätte weiter scrollen müssen.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht bei mir.
Das geht nicht.
Ich kann ja nichts setten.
Das ist ja das Problem.
Der kann die Karte querien.
Das geht ja bei mir schon gar nicht.
Guck, wenn ich das mache.
mst start
also man muss immer muss okay mst geht ja bei mir nicht
stopp ok ab install x off ab install auf was muss man da eigentlich alles in serie wird install kvm
wird wird manager debian keine ahnung was man dafür alles ist was man alles installiert kvm
Wirt Manager, install qemo, ok, äh, minus x, ok, x ice, ich will einfach nur gucken ob
xv-modding funktioniert.
Install xasd.
Wir haben x11-Utils oder irgendein Gedöns.
Muss man da
installieren.
Ah, x11-Apps.
Genau.
Okay.
Bestes Tool.
So.
xv-modding funktioniert.
Wirt-Manager.
Äh, was?
Achso, ähm...
Okay.
Ich muss meinen User noch hinzufügen,
dass der LibWirt machen darf.
Proops.
Wirt.
Wie heißt mein User?
Debian.
Okay.
Wirt Manager.
Ah, schon viel besser.
Neue VM.
Ich muss Dings downloaden.
Debian.
Wie ist das Ding? Bullseye Download.
Äh
Wo gibt es denn da noch ein Iso?
Da muss es ja noch eins geben
Download Debian 11 ISO.
meinetwegen
archiv 11
11 amd 64 iso cd install ok sagt copy link
also local install media yes bros ach so und das muss wohin muss das nach
debian nach war lepp lepp wird images
refresh
so als db 11 automatisch ja ja ok was das lag
ja drei cpu 490 next wunderbar network selection nut bridge device
kannst ruhig nut machen das okay ist mir egal hast du mal ist bevor install
ok passt das war erstmal installieren wir erstmal db an beginn installation
installiert aber schnell db an hier grafik install ist so was
kann man das hier vielleicht ein bisschen riesen
englisch aber europe man kann das leider nicht gescheit in
container machen hallo ich möchte die germany
die map german wie das flutscht hier in der vm also die kiste hat schon ein bisschen power
dhcp
db a2 wir haben ja schon gut passt war nicht nur user max dass ich unterscheiden
kann 123456 massive super secure passwort
ich habe ich habe wird manager auf meinem nass laufen und per xv die hier
rüber geholt also es läuft auf einem nass deswegen ist es auch so schnell
Gibt es den nicht mehr für MacOS?
Naja gut, also
den Client, du kannst ja den Client installieren
und dich dann
auf eine LibVirt übers Netzwerk verbinden.
Deswegen wäre es gut, wenn es den auch für
andere Betriebssysteme gibt. Der LibVirt Manager
ist echt ganz praktisch.
Ich meine, schönste Interface ist es nicht,
aber ich habe jetzt halt gerade nichts anderes.
Ach, Debian schon 5.10 Körner.
Ja, das ist schön alt.
Dann funzt das hoffentlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da...
Kann man da PCI Path Through und sowas einstellen?
Leute, wir haben übrigens ein Problem.
Wenn ich jetzt die Netzwerkkarte durchreiche in die VM,
dann geht der Host nicht mehr.
Aber ich habe doch eigentlich auch noch eine zweite Netzwerkkarte hier dran.
Warum wird die nicht benutzt?
Doch, die ist sogar verbunden.
Wartet mal.
Oh.
Germany.
Depp.
Jawohl.
Wir waren erstmal bis der fertigen Ziel ist.
unterstützt die melanox karte überhaupt efi boot ich glaube schon
ich war es ist wahrscheinlich der kram ist ja nicht teuer
wenn ich mir eine cx 4 kaufe ja die bei ebay oder gebraucht bei amazon
Moment, das ist der Dreier
Chat, was ist denn das hier?
Das ist irgendein Serverport, oder?
Das ist kein PC-Express.
Also das Zeug, guck mal, so was hier.
Das Zeug ist nicht wirklich irgendwie super teuer.
Können wir mal bei Amazon gucken.
Aber Amazon ist wieder sinnlos.
Also ich finde schon was.
Ich kann auch die Onboard-Karte nehmen.
Aber ich fuck's einfach ab, dass das so kompliziert ist.
Das ist das Ding
Es fuckt mich ab
Wo wir jetzt hier, also während das installiert
Müssen wir grad mal was gucken
IP Link Show
Hallo
Vnet 0 haben wir.
Wollen wir Vnet 0?
Chat, wo ist denn meine andere Netzwerkkarte?
Oh, fuck. Was ist das für ein Kernel?
No.
Oh, nee.
Leute, heute ist aber echt ätzend.
Wisst ihr was?
Meine Onboard-Netzwerkkarte,
die ist zu neu.
Die kann Debian Bookworm noch nicht.
Ich installiere jetzt Windows, Alter.
Ich installiere jetzt Bookworm, Alter.
Install Chrome Bootloader to your primary device.
Ja, ist es.
Ich installiere jetzt Windows.
Mir egal.
Boah, da kriege ich Anfälle, wenn ich Windows installieren muss, Alter.
Da drehe ich jetzt schon am Rad.
Classic.
Okay, das hat so keinen Sinn
Also hier mit dem Kram kriegen wir es ja nicht
irgendwie nicht gebacken
Aber Chad, wisst ihr was ich mache?
Ich hab mir doch diesen ganzen Kram
hier hin kopiert, ne?
Ob er sich jetzt Windows installiert hat?
Ubuntu 16 bringt es uns doch gar nicht.
Also es hängt ja letztendlich daran, dass das Image Generation Tool missing ist.
Hinten wir das nicht noch irgendwo?
Mick?
Das haben wir doch bestimmt, irgendwo dieses Image Generation Tool.
Vielleicht ist es hier drinnen.
Mick?
Äh.
Old MFT
Uninstall.
Melanox MIG Tool Download.
Vielleicht gibt es das auch extra.
Ah, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Ab, ab, search, search, MST.
Vielleicht ist es da drin.
Warte mal, vielleicht...
Moment, ich hab das doch...
Ich hab doch hier das Nix-US-Zeug noch installiert.
Ist da vielleicht Mick drinne?
Mick?
Äh.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Nix Packages.
Sekunde.
Melanox.
Was haben wir da hier Schönes?
Ah, nur das hier.
Okay.
schiebt doch die firma in deine bulls ivm bau dort das simulschiff zurück du hast recht du
hast recht ja klar ich habe daran gedacht ich müsste das alles in der in der form aber du
hast recht natürlich ich brauche ich muss ja nur das bilden darin machen ja ja du hast ja
recht habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht ist da habe ich hier eine netzwerkkarte
jetzt eigentlich drin network adapter chat ist hier da ist hier ist hier in
nick ja okay ich bräuchte bridge device oder mac wie tabby tabb geht auch da kann ich mir
drauf einloggen. Äh, MacVtab für EMP Dingsbums da. Warte mal, warte mal. WTO, WTO.
Vice Slam, das da wollen wir haben.
Guess is not running. Okay, jetzt aber, ha?
Äh, Max?
Hoch?
Äh, aus irgendwelchen Gründen darf ich nichts tippen.
Es wird ja immer besser.
Ah, jetzt, okay.
Max?
IP-Add.
Ja, 103, okay.
SSR 1 und 2, 1, 2, 3.
Max?
xs schiebt diesen kämpfer auf desktop 3 wird es mir zu viel die es jeder sind wir auf der kiste
drauf ist ein linux von field bainer ist aus dem aktuellen verzeichnis aus dem posten der sucht
das unter user bin ich muss ein verzeichnis mountain es gibt doch hier
man konnte doch mal wird fs machen anders das alte dem jan hier schon wird
fs system wird die fs genau so aus path will ich
location images
es die mitschloss
in den E
die auf ein System
ich will
ich will gut
Nein! Jetzt ist der Scheiß doch gecrashed, Alter!
Boah, fuck!
Abartig.
Add.
File System.
Source Path.
Add.
Root.
Oh, wurscht.
0w das will ich haben.
Choose Volume, Target Path.
MNT?
Wie muss denn das heißen?
Okay, Finish.
Add device, by running.
und support was chat memory ok das was mich hier ich kopiere das mir einfach runter
wir kopieren uns das einfach von root und war jetzt einfach ct cp minus r 0 nach home max
Home Debian
Irgendwie braucht das jetzt 3 Stunden
Aber es wird schon passen
So, CHMOD777
Home Debian
0w
Minus R
So und jetzt
CP
CP Debian
0w hier hin
CP minus R
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Da ist es.
CP minus R.
0 W nach 3.
Oh nein.
Ah, ist auch falsch.
Falscher User.
Da ist der User ja.
Max.
Okay.
Nice.
Ist der Kram übertragen?
Habe nämlich einfach den ganzen Scheiß rüber kopiert.
So.
Zudo Minusi.
Home Max 0w.
So, welche Version mussten wir jetzt installieren?
Die da, ne?
Ach ne, Moment mal.
Ne, ne, Moment mal.
Die hier, die hier.
Upt Install Linux Headers AMD64.
Was riecht ja krampf.
Das würde am Ende trotzdem nicht funktionieren, ey.
Das ist Hyper-Up-Fuck, ey.
Ich find's ein bisschen geil.
Immerhin. Immerhin Entertainment-Faktor.
Hoffe ich mal.
Das ist doch richtig eklig, ey.
Also, ich hätte am Anfang nicht gedacht,
dass das so ein Riesenakt ist.
App install,
Build Essentials.
Brauchen wir wahrscheinlich.
Ja, brauchen wir wahrscheinlich.
essential und dkms braumer noch egal dass wir jetzt gleich sehen das wird
der wird wird ja sagen wenn das aber ich brauchte sehen also hier in store
abt install dkms ja sag ich doch
Ich habe übrigens noch eine idee wir können uns für das demian für mein host demian einfach den netzwerk treiber kompilieren
Den für meine onboard netzwerkkarte
okay das immer als jetzt funktioniert jura sky ja dankeschön für den raid rock leute ihr wollt euch
das aber wahrscheinlich nicht geben ich versuche seit vier stunden meine netzwerkkarte zu flashen
damit ich px e boot aktivieren kann und es ist nicht ich gebe zu die netzwerkkarte ist ein altes
Stück Dreck.
Aber ich wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Und das funzt nicht.
MST Start.
Sehr gut.
Okay, jetzt haben wir hier den Kram.
Und jetzt können wir sagen... Wie war das
nochmal? Burn?
Burn?
Ja, das da brauchen wir, ne?
So muss das sein.
For Science, genau.
So.
Image Generation was successful!
Pogu!
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise funktioniert.
Das sah ich schon gleich dabei, ne?
So, wo liegt denn jetzt das Image?
Hier, da ist es.
Okay, dann müssen wir das wieder rüber kopieren.
Ähm.
Moment. SCP.
Ich bin verwirrt. Wartet mal.
SCP.
So, Moment, Moment. Wir wollen jetzt von hier...
Wir wollen jetzt von hier...
...das da kopieren.
Hierhin.
Und jetzt wollen wir...
...FW Connect.
Wer sich fragt, warum ich das nicht mache,
von einer VM auf die andere.
Das ist über MacVTab. MacVTab
kann die VM nicht mit dem Host kommunizieren.
Auch eklig, ne?
So, und das soll jetzt
dahin.
Äh, nicht wirklich dahin.
Äh.
Vor allem, es soll Debian sein.
Debian.
Und da kann es einfach so heißen.
Okay.
So, also jetzt müssen wir nochmal nachgucken,
Wie fontst das jetzt?
Home, Max.
Chat.
Ach so.
Ey.
Das ist die falsche Kiste.
Oh, jetzt wird es aber langsam verwirrend.
Home Max
Home Debian
FW Connect
So, jetzt müssen wir uns nochmal hier
den Post raussuchen.
Also, wie ging das jetzt weiter?
Wir gucken nochmal, ob ich auch das Richtige hier hatte.
Ähm.
Inni.
So müsste es sein.
Wim.
Inni.
Wim installiert.
Intel Arc B85 zu flashen?
Die kann auch SLA.
Ja mit dem unterschied wahrscheinlich dass es zumindest halbwegs offiziell ist oder
Angeblich ist es auch offiziell ich weiß nicht
Da ich in der falschen rolle bin angeblich ist es auch halbwegs offiziell dass die karte das kann aber es ist so ein
ultrakrasser abfuck das zu installieren das ist
Okay das haben wir jetzt gemacht
verifiziert die daten der firma matches the card you want to ride
wo sich das
kommt das war immer
gg
ach ja
Einfach mal
Random Scripts ausführen
Von irgendwelchen Leuten aus dem Internet
Okay
Anscheinend alles okay, was auch immer
Okay, also
ID
Burn
The new firmware is older.
Ich weiß. Ich weiß. Ich weiß.
Yes.
Burn will not be failed if.
So, mal gucken,
ob jetzt wirklich das SAIOV
gleich aktiviert ist. Okay.
Blind.
Mal kurz was checken.
Ja, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Ja, das suche ich.
Okay, das Flaschen hat funktioniert.
Jetzt muss ich noch rebooten.
Ja, ja, ich muss jetzt auch noch rebooten.
Ja.
Erstmal rebooten.
Schade nichts.
Lass die nur gucken, dass die neue Firmware drauf ist.
Ich will nicht PXE
Removen, ich bin ja froh, dass das Ding
PXE am Start hat
Da muss ich hier noch irgendwelche
Okay, müsste eigentlich wieder da sein.
Oder auch nicht. Chat.
Pass auf, jetzt haben wir die Netzwerkkarte geprickt wahrscheinlich.
Oh, haben wir anscheinend wirklich.
Ja, ne, ne, haben wir nicht.
Okay, okay, haben wir nicht.
Ich hab schon gedacht,
ich hätt mich sogar gefreut,
wenn ich die Netzwerkkarte geprickt hätte.
Wäre jetzt endlich Schluss gewesen.
Hätte ich sagen können, okay, fertig,
wir haben es komplett zerstört.
Boah,
Oh, ohne Scheiß, jetzt wurde es hier gerade
hingen, ja.
Hätte ich echt gedacht, jetzt random geht es auf einmal.
So, und was muss ich jetzt noch machen?
Ja.
Mod-Probe.
Ja, gut, zack.
Ähm.
Ja, gut.
Wenn ich meine Netzwerkkarte remove,
pass mal auf, bam, jetzt ist natürlich meine
Verbindung weg, ne, logisch.
Da muss ich mir jetzt...
MLX4 Core brauchen wir.
Okay.
Ähm.
144.
Zack.
Oh, ich hab schon wieder so viele Tabs auf.
Move nach rechts.
Ähm.
Debian.
Okay, machen wir das hier.
Was müssen wir?
Mod...
Modprobe.
MLX4 Core, ne?
Okay.
Nice.
Mein Switch...
plinkt.
Aber Lied kann...
Jetzt, jetzt, okay
Okay, der hat mehrere Ports
Das ist schon mal
Interesting
Ich würde sagen, es funzt.
SAEV scheint aktiv zu sein.
Jetzt, okay, okay.
Nächste Preisfrage.
Nachdem die Netzwerkkarte ja nicht mit diesem komischen Config-Tool zu setzen ist, ja.
Das funzt ja nicht.
Nach wie vor, funzt ja nicht.
wie setze ich über die config wie setze ich da drin jetzt px e boot auf aktiviert man
gehen muss das ja irgendwie wir müssen übrigens erste mal wird manager wieder unsere andere dem
Demian-VM starten.
Brauchen wir dann nämlich gleich zum
Compile-Zorn.
Ne, Chat,
wir machen jetzt was anderes.
Wir machen jetzt was anderes.
Ich will, dass meine andere
Netzwerkkarte geht. Dann greife ich nämlich über die andere
Netzwerkkarte zu und das andere Ding
reiche ich durch in die Demian-VM.
Ne, ne, ne.
Es geht mir um die
Netzwerkkarte selbst. Die Netzwerkkarte
die hat, also für den
Host, ja, die hat PXE
ausgeschaltet und ich wähle
das, die auch theoretisch möglich ist, PXE
zu booten. Einfach nur so,
weil es geht. Und weil ich da drüber wahrscheinlich
über meinen PXE-Server Kram installieren kann.
So, warte mal.
RT-R
R8127
Driver Download
Realtek
Drivers
Das kann mein Kernel nämlich noch nicht.
Linux
an m-a
den da brauche ich
das gab diese captchas habe ich ja ewig nicht gesehen aber wer diese
Real-Tex-Seite macht, das ist auch
echt Pains-Champ.
Copy-Download-Link.
Also.
Was
steht da darunter?
BZ2.
Blub.ta.bz2.
Wie? Wie?
How to
anta BZ2. Was weiß ich?
Das benutzt man nie.
How to extract. Sehr gut.
da sind wir, CD RTL, ja, ne nicht RTL, Make, ah, oh, excellent, äh, hat das jetzt funktioniert?
ich glaube schon, make install
nice
mod probe
R8127
irgendwas nicht funktioniert?
oh, oh, es hat nicht funktioniert
äh, wahrscheinlich weil OpenMessage
nicht installiert ist, oder?
warte mal, chat hat es jetzt
funktioniert oder nicht?
äh, ich bin
bin grad sehr verwirrt
krypto da fehlt bestimmt auch messer selber
was das mit die eier für den scheiß erzählt
ein bock ich habe kein secure boot oder irgendwas an
Ach, du meinst nur installieren?
Mocktool oder wie heißt dieses Ding?
Mockutil oder sowas?
Das da meinst du oder was?
Oder wie?
Ist es installiert?
Oh, was könnte das jetzt sein?
Ich würde auch sagen, dass der
install lippssl braucht openssl
lippssl def genau chat
weg clean weg
Nee, nee, der hat irgendwelche Schmerzen mit.
Ich meine, ist das wirklich ein Error?
Oder?
Ja.
Ich meine, wenn es nicht gesigned ist, ist es auch nicht wild.
Das hat, glaube ich, schon...
Doch, das hat schon funktioniert.
Ich glaube schon.
Da ist es doch.
Aber das ist nicht...
Das ist ja nicht geladen.
Aber warum nicht?
Hä?
Aber das heißt doch so.
Nee, nee, geladen ist das nicht.
Ja, um mich zu sehen.
Achso.
Easy.
Okay, nice.
So.
Da ist er.
Da ist die Netzwerkkarte.
Da ist die IP-Link-Show.
Ja.
Das habe ich nicht gelesen.
So.
Da sind wir.
Hier.
ENP.
Die da brauchen wir.
IP Link so wie ging das jetzt noch mal
habe ich doch habe ich doch oder ich habe doch hier etc modules
Ja da, da habe ich das. So, alles klar. Also, jetzt haben wir die Netzwerkkarte hier am Start.
Da können wir jetzt ja auch einfach mal sagen, wir nehmen jetzt einfach eine freie Netzwerkkarte.
Habe ich noch ifconfig? Da weiß ich wenigstens nicht, wie es funktioniert.
ab install if konfine tools muss man dann glaube ich für ins ziel und netz
konfig if konfig wie jetzt noch mal ein ding spung
Tete.
Ähm.
Zwei Punkten, aber hier
54.
Äh.
Ne, das muss vorne hin, oder?
ENP
4S0. Ja.
Slash 24 ab.
Okay.
So, und jetzt sollten wir eigentlich
uns da verbinden
können auf 54.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Wirtmanager.
Ja.
Er möge connecten, please.
Ja, CU.
Und jetzt kriegt er hier die
Netzwerkkarte durch
gereicht.
PCI-Device?
Alter, ja.
Ich unloade
mal kurz Melanox auf dem Host.
Nur mal, um sicher zu gehen.
Mod Pro
Mod Pro minus R
MLX 4
4 Core war das, ne?
Is in use.
Kann ich das irgendwie...
wie anjusen ja ich muss wahrscheinlich die netzwerkkarte runterfahren
ifconfig
down
Oh.
Oh, ein Futsa-Set.
So.
Ist in use. Warum ist denn das in use?
Keine Ahnung.
Kann ich das einfach so durchreichen?
Dann entlädt er das.
Ja, das da.
Das will ich durch.
LS-Mod.
Ach, deswegen
hat er davor diesen ganzen anderen krempel auch anlodet verstehe okay sehr gut ja
ed hardware
pc
melanox
da bin ich
wo ist es da sagt dachte das was ach so ja ja hier ganz ehrlich eigentlich kann kann man das
ja auch irgendwie einmal zwei netzwerk anzeige
erstartet
SSH
sollten, hoffentlich
wir die gleiche IP kriegen wie vorher.
Haben wir die gleiche
IP wie vorher? Ja, sehr gut.
So, weil
MST startet.
Hä? Guck mal.
Meine, meine, meine
Das ist ja dämlich, Alter
Die, die Netzwerkkarte ist irgendwie nicht kompatibel
Mit dem Tool von
In dieser Version
Okay, oh meine Güte
Das ist ja mal do... Oh, ist das dämlich, ey
Boah, ist das dämlich, man
Wahrscheinlich ist die Firma jetzt schon wieder zu neu
Das ist die 410er
Das ist die 410er, die ich hier hab
Guck, das ist die 410er
Ich hab gedacht, das lag am zu neuen Linux-Körnel
Ist es aber nicht
Na gut, das ist jetzt ja nicht weiter schlimm
Das ist nur ein extra
Step im Endeffekt
Weil
Mein größtes Problem, was ich jetzt habe
Ist, ich hab keine Ahnung
Aber wisst ihr, was wir
Nochmal probieren können?
Wenn wir da eh schon gerade hier dabei sind
Wenn wir da eh schon gerade dabei sind
home max lol wie an installen das jetzt noch mal
ja
ja an installen das jetzt noch mal und jetzt installieren wir mal weil das ist ja angeblich
auch eine version die gut funktioniert 20er installieren wir jetzt mal gucken ob es dann
aus irgendwelchen kunden geht
msd start so msc also mst config mft config alter mlx config abkürzung der
f msc rpci config irgendwas okay das liegt nicht am einbetriebssystem das ist einfach
irgendwie prinzipiell kaputt dann ist jetzt nur die große preisfrage wie kriegen wir hier
rein in diese config datei dass ich pxe boot machen möchte
melanox enable pxe
wartet mal kurz es hat geklingelt was da los
okay
auch wieder erst in einer der betteln will aber bloß auf
ich sehe es auf der kamera
Ja, das kann ich halt nicht machen und das nervt.
Gut, Option.
Äh, Eni, Melanox.
Ähm, wir hatten doch hier
S3, Melanox,
Enable, PXE.
Das ist jetzt noch das letzte, was wir hinkriegen müssen.
PXE-Enable für das Ding.
Und dann, und dann, kann ich die Karte
dahin schmeißen,
was sie verdient hat, nämlich in den Müll.
Ich glaube nur nicht, dass ich den Scheiß
benutze.
Es geht bloß darum,
ich will es jetzt hinkriegen.
Wir haben ja fast alles
schon geschafft.
Okay, komm, wir sind jetzt, wir fragen jetzt, wir fragen jetzt hier auch nochmal AI.
Z-Maus, klein.
Jet-KPT.
Wie enable ich PXE gut über die INI-Datei?
Das wird jetzt nicht wirklich was zu sagen können.
Okay.
Wollen wir das dem mal glauben?
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob das stimmt?
Glauben wir dem, dass das stimmt?
Man findet hier nichts in der Inni, ne?
Okay.
Wir haben SRIOV aktiviert.
Das hat funktioniert.
Ne, man muss da True reinschreiben anscheinend.
So.
Weiter bei, warum ist es Exp und nicht PXE?
Jetzt müssen wir es nochmal flashen.
Burn.
Image Channel.
Ach, ich kack.
Noob.
Ich habe es falsch installiert.
Und ähm.
Da liegt so viel rum.
Ähm.
MST.
wie heißt das mft 21 habe ich 20 habe ich installiert an install mft 10 das
brauchen wir 10 installen
die musik passt gut ja in der drama fs ne da brauche ich jetzt gerade start
gut okay fw
Burn.
Achso, ich bin eins verkehrt.
Aha.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Leute, ich muss mal ganz dringend
pissen. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Wieder am Start.
Leute, ich bin 5 Stunden schon online.
Nur um
PXE-Boot quasi zu...
Aha.
Die...
Die AI labert wieder.
Ich glaube, die AI labert einfach nur ganz wildes Zeug.
Gerade hat absolut keine Ahnung, ey.
So, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Ne.
Die hat absolut keine Ahnung.
Kann man das, kann man das überhaupt setzen hier drüber?
Weil das Problem ist, ich habe ja auch noch nicht mal eine Ahnung, wohin damit.
exp rom uefi in ebens im wo könnten das noch hinkommen
das ist eine ganz schön ganz schön lange config file
und die n
das habe doch schon probiert das ist doch eines der probleme warum sie ganze mist nicht
funktioniert weil dieses komische konflikt tool irgendwie nicht in der lage ist was anzuzeigen für meine netzwerkkarte
Wir sind jetzt halt wieder so im territorium wo wirklich noch nie jemand so was gemacht hat
Auf der ganzen welt nicht
Okay, ne, das
funktioniert nicht.
Aber woher weiß ich denn?
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal.
MLX Burn.
Check das doch. Da gucken wir jetzt Strings
nach.
Warte mal. Bridge, MLX
Burn.
muss doch da irgendwo drin stehen okay da ist es ein schild skript das schild skript
Woher weiß der denn?
4.354 Zeilen
Was? Oh, da kämpfe ich mich jetzt nicht durch.
Das sage ich euch. Da kämpfe ich mich.
Woher weiß der denn,
dass es irgendwas
nicht gibt?
Ja, jetzt ist es
successful. Klar.
Hör mal aus und schau,
was passiert. Du meinst mit S-Trace oder was?
Aber da ist auch...
Alles klar.
Da müssen wir jetzt nochmal irgendwas reinschreiben, was verkehrt ist.
Boah, nee, das ist mir zu...
Aber da hat es schon wieder aufgeräumt.
Wir können mal gucken wo diese Fehlermeldung kommt.
Auf keiner von Pfeil eigentlich nix.
Здесь, Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь
Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь
Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь
Здесь Здесь Здесь Здесь
Здесь Здесь Здесь
Здесь Здесь
Здесь
Das hatten wir doch schon, oder?
Ähm, ja dann.
Ach!
Mick macht das wahrscheinlich.
Generate hier.
Ja.
Running
Mic CMD.
Ähm, wir können doch bestimmt
Debug oder sowas
sagen.
Seht ihr
irgendwas? Verbose oder so?
Just D, Debug.
Seht ihr da irgendwas?
Was?
Was ist das?
Z P X E N?
Aber, aber wie verwende ich denn das jetzt?
px
Wie viel fützt das jetzt wird es ist es kann auch kein mensch lesen hier
Also eigentlich müsste es doch nur
mit Z
PXEN
1? Ne, hä?
Also sowas hier?
Port 1 enabled?
Nee.
Das ist aber nett.
Jetzt müssen wir die Indie noch mal kurz editieren,
dass er nach Funst...
Also Funst?
Gleich zu?
Alter, diese dumme Seite, Mann.
Das ist aber mal tatsächlich was,
wo uns die AI helfen könnte.
So Dinger checken die manchmal ganz gut.
Syntaktisch falsch ist.
Die korrekte erfordert Leerzeichen zwischen dem Flagg und dem Album, welches zudem in dem Format startet und geht.
Also.
Äh.
Bin ich verarscht? Das hab ich doch.
Hä?
Das hab ich doch.
Achso, ja.
Das hatte ich vorher, aber das ging ja auch nicht.
ja ja das hatte ich auch vor das ging auch nicht
nun ist er ist nun syntaktisch korrekt
ist kein wunder dass es business enterprise software ist
ach du meinst das muss gar nicht in die firma sondern muss da direkt ein device angeben jetzt
dafür
meinst du also quasi dev mst ach das ist ja zernet installierte ok
der schmachs bis besser leistet recht ok also dann muss ich jetzt das muss ich
das alte wieder an installen meine güte was ein mft 10 an install mft 25 die
ging ja gerade noch so install
mft start mst statt was haben sie sich da eigentlich ausgedacht bei jetzt mal
ernsthaft meist es mlx war es ist mst mal ist es mft kein wunder dass du dir
dafür für tausende euro support kaufen muss weil der kram einfach so beschissen
ist dass keine sau durchblickt wahrscheinlich blickt nicht mal die
support mitarbeiter durch ein browser hat übrigens 100 prozent cpu last auf
einem kern weil weil ich zu viel zeug auf ok mlx bern mx bern mst pci und das kann jetzt weg
Wie jetzt?
Was will das jetzt von mir?
Wie?
Oh mein Gott.
Oh mein Gott, das hat die Option jetzt nicht mehr.
Stimmt.
Was für ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
ok dann mft 425 an install mft 20 hier install
Ah!
Jätke!
Wir haben die richtige Version erwischt, die das noch unterstützt.
Ups.
Ja, jetzt habe ich zu früh Enter gedrückt.
Ähm
Ja, mach
By the way, habt ihr hier in der Hilfe
Irgendwas gesehen für UEFI Boot
Oder so
Zum Einschalten
Ne, oder
Aber hier gibt es einen PXE-ROM-File.
Weil ich brauche ja EFI-Boot,
nicht wirklich PXE-Boot.
Schon PXE-Boot.
Ah, das wäre es jetzt auch gewesen,
wenn das funktioniert hätte.
Ja, wenn das funktionieren würde, aber ist das... funktioniert das vielleicht?
Das wird es nicht sein, aber... ne.
Das wäre auch zu einfach. Was ist, wenn ich Query mache?
Query?
Let's query da was.
Okay
Ich mein, wir haben jetzt immerhin
PXE aktiviert
Muss sie für 2 auch aktiviert werden?
Ganz im Ernst, ich enable das einfach mal für 2, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie der das intern sieht.
Meine Netzwerkkarte hat nur einen Port, ne?
Was passiert, wenn ich Port Zero sage?
Oh, äh
Äh
Negative Shift
Wir machen mal Port 1
Also im Prinzip lassen wir das mal so
Was passiert denn, wenn ich 3 angib?
Ach, das ist ein Binary Flag
1, 2, 4
Das ist, ne, ne, ne, das ist ein Binary
Ne, ähm
Das nächste müsste 8 sein
Ja
Okay, egal, wir
Rebooten jetzt
Schauen wir mal kurz.
Oh, ich bin zu langsam.
Ich bin zu langsam.
Reboot.
Okay, jetzt rebootet es.
Ja, Pseudo-Power-Off.
Ich habe keinen
VM-Agent installiert. Das dauert ewig.
Du hast die VM rebooted? Ne, habe ich nicht.
Jetzt habe ich beides rebooted.
Okay.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal hier ganz schnell
Nö, ist nix zu sehen.
Nö, nix zu sehen von...
Nee, nichts zu sehen.
Per PXE-Boot.
Okay, Chat.
Dann.
Machen wir jetzt an der Stelle für heute mal Schluss.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab mich sehr gefreut,
dass so viele Leute dabei waren.
Und sich den Kram angeguckt haben,
wie grausam das ist.
Das war wirklich absolut lächerlich.
Wer nächstes Mal wieder mit dabei ist,
ich kann nicht.
Leute, ich lass es.
Ihr könnt ja jetzt einmal auf Follow drücken, wenn es euch gefallen hat
Und wenn ihr das nächste Mal wieder mit am Start sein wollt
Morgen früh bin ich wahrscheinlich da
Oh, das reicht mir jetzt, ey
Kein Bock mehr
Bis dann, macht's gut
Elfte haben wir geschafft
Macht's gut, CU